e
my mic on so I'll try again um it being
I'm going to go with 10:4 so I'm to make
our clerk after to weedo things here uh
open the meeting with of uh finance
division 2 and welcome the folks from un
and please introduce yourselves and and
uh begin good morning Mr chair members
of the committee my name is Katherine
prenter I serve as the chancellor of our
state's University system and with me is
Lauren Banker our um government
relations director yeah nice to see you
all so we passed out um a dozen or so
slides I'd like to walk you through
those um we've ALS Al provided two
letters of support one from the business
and industry Association and one from
the New Hampshire Life Sciences
Association and you'll recall that um
when we were here in January to provide
an orientation to division 2 walked
through a lot of information about
enrollment demographics the number of
students the programs that we have that
relate to Workforce needs what we've
been doing about it I'm not going to
repeat that information information that
I provided I'm happy to answer any
questions but we walked through quite a
bit of material when we were here in
January for
orientation so um on on slide two I
provide this because um frankly I look
at it fairly frequently to remind myself
the importance of the work uh that's
done across the university system this
is section one of RSA
187a it's the enable aing legislation
that uh creates the university
system and um the university system is
to provide programs which serve the
needs of the state and the nation
research which contributes to the
welfare of mankind to the development of
faculty and to the educational
experience of students for its faculty
and staff to bring educational resources
and professional experience to the
benefit of the state and the state's
people um
this is our mission and we take it very
seriously and of course I'm probably
biased but the university system is good
at what it does and um it is a
tremendous resource to the state as a
whole to our businesses and to the
citizenry so just want to start with
that on slide three is a summary of the
governor's recommended budget the
governor's recommended budget bium over
bium
including the one-time funding I'll talk
about that in just a minute it's a um
$16.5 million reduction in University
system funding um from 2425 to 2627
that's about 8.3%
reduction um and we will feel that
reduction I'll talk a minute about other
costs we have to take out of our cost
structure and um we respectfully request
that state funding be held at the
government Governor's
level not flat funding but not a deeper
cut than the
88.3% we have modeled out what that
looks like at 91.2 million we know in
fiscal 26 we have to take out about $20
million in cost out of our cost
structure and we're working toward that
as I mentioned
earlier the um we talked about during
the orientation we've reduced employ
headcount we've reduced medical benefits
increased premiums we've reduced
retirement contributions we're selling
property we're getting out of leases um
we recognize with a decline in
enrollment we must um act prudently and
decisions so on slide four again quick
recap our total enrollment in the fall
of 24 was 23
3,000 um our our res non resident
non-resident split is about 5050 across
the university system 83% of our uh
students are
undergrads UNH makes up about 69% of our
total enrollment with Keane at 14% And
Plymouth at
177% the University system is a
significant driver for Workforce
pipeline each year about 3,000 are of
our graduates enter the New Hampshire
Workforce we have relationships with
thousands of businesses across um the
state um again which I think is
indicative of the letters of support
that you've received from the business
and industry Association and the New
Hampshire Life Sciences
Association UNH is one of only 187
universities in the country that are
classified as R1 R1 is a carneg Carnegie
classification which indicates highest
level of research which is very
impressive for a university the size of
unh now I will tell you if you go back
and look at the material from the
orientation the number was one out of
146 but now it's 187 so um also Keenan
Plymouth much smaller institutions but
they are deeply embedded in in the badok
region and the Lakes region in the North
country
okay so Slide Five I want to take some
time and walk through some numbers I
think
sometimes um maybe it's a mystery of
what the finances of the University
system are and how it works so this is a
highlevel summary I just want to walk
you through some line items and this is
a snapshot um again a summary from the
University Systems audited financial
statements the income statement profit
and loss statement from 2019 and
2024 you might say why did Kathy use
2019 well the covid years make it very
difficult sometimes to look at the
audited financial statements and make a
comparison with all the federal dollars
that were coming in with the room and
board we had to rebate all of that so I
I just want to walk through this is a
five-year change on our income statement
so you'll see tuition and the Top Line
gross tuition and fees has
dropped even though there there's been
no price increase on New Hampshire
resident students during that time there
has been a price increase on
non-resident students about 2 and a
half% per year but you still see a
decline in that gross because our
enrollment is
declining on the second line You'll see
at the same time time that gross tuition
and fees has declined our financial aid
has
increased which is why over that same
time period for our New Hampshire
students net tuition and fees on average
has actually dropped during that time
period so this net tuition fees that
highlighted
row that's dropped
15% and that's what's available if you
will for the University system
to um run its operation ations as as far
as tuition and fees goes auxiliary
Services that's room and board primarily
room and board that's increased because
we've had price
increases the next line is an important
one it's grants and contracts we talked
a little bit about this during
orientation grants and contracts you'll
see our research Enterprise has
increased significantly over that those
five years that also includes pel grants
which is about 20 Mill ion 22 million so
there's not a big change in that line
from pel Grants but Federal research
grants have significantly increased
which is why in a minute I'll show you
you'll see increases in
spend from research right a dollar for
the most part a dollar in is a dollar
out um State Appropriations that 21%
increase in the five years includes uh
$3 million in fiscal 24 of one-time
money that was appropriated for Plymouth
and
Keane if we if we look at the recurring
if you will a recurring uh Grant um that
increase from 19 to 24 fiscal 19 to 24
is about a 177% increase in state
Appropriations which the university
system and our students very much appre
appreciate that's how we've been able to
keep New Hampshire tuition flat for the
first time this fall for the first time
since
2013 our New Hampshire resident student
population increased and I really
believe uh a lot of that has to do with
being able to keep New Hampshire tuition
flat and and why is that
important we know that our New Hampshire
resident students are more likely to
stay and work here in our state
um so you'll see employee
compensation has increased 6% over those
5 years over a time period where
inflation was
23% and over a time period that research
increased
59% so if I would pull
out research uh Grant funded positions
our employee comp actually
dropped the supplies and services line
you see that significant increase also a
lot of that has to do with the research
dollars so if we have
subcontracts if there's equipment
involved that that would be in that line
and that increase is a direct result of
that re that
Grant increas in Grant funded
research I do want to point out this
this often comes up as a question
relative to
endowments so the University
System including the UNH Foundation Keen
state has a small Foundation the value
of the all the endowments at June 30 of
24 was $988 Million which is a very big
number almost all of that remember UNH
has been around for 150 years so it's
donor monies that are designated for
specific purposes also included in that
is um many years of the unique college
scholarship program um there are also
what we call quasi endowments uh it's a
financing tool if we've issued um debt
and it's going to be a a a bullet payout
years from now we've put money aside so
we're ready to pay that bullet when it
comes due so that endowment pays out and
this is what also very common pays out
about 42% per year you say why 42% per
year because we we want to minimize
volatility if you have a year that the
stock market drops 15% we still want to
be able to pay out that 4 and a half%
because it's funding scholarships and a
number of other things so what pays out
each year is4 to $45 million for
scholarships for um there is a piece
about $12 million a year supports our
campus budgets so that that is all part
of the endowment now that line that says
endowment gifts and
returns that's primarily market gains on
that some years are much better than
others but again we try to minimize
volatility um ALS so well it's up to the
committee chair happy to take questions
during our time or we can wait until the
end and as always Lauren and I will all
happily follow up with material if we
haven't covered some of your questions
morning representative Murray thank you
just quick since we're on this um with
regards to the endowment um some of the
organizations will use rolling quarters
um in or so what is your Ro you know how
do you what what goes into the what
determines the payout it's the average
um Market or fair value over 12 Rolling
quarters
quarters get my notebook out in case
with that's it that's it who for now
okay that's wow um any others
so I have a couple of questions for you
then sure what has the increase been in
administrative salaries over this time
period specific to administrative
salaries I'll have to can I get that for
I'll follow up yeah if you don't have it
me I'm just going to keep a list here
representative so we can follow up after
the hearing and I think you gave the
percentage but I wasn't quick enough to
get it down but in any case while
students population's been declining
increasing total employee compensation
yeah is that what you said right here 6%
that I will say what what I would like
to get for you is Break It Out by grants
and non-g grants because as the grants
the research dollars have increased by
59% some some of that compensation will
relate to okay researchers that had to
that were hired to during that so I will
get for you by Grant funded and
non-grant funded what's happened with
the employee compensation perfect and
then compensation per student is what
I'm looking for compensation for per
student in other words account for the
fact that your population of students
has been declining with
okay uh representative papovich and if I
may just add a little to what chairman
Earth was asking when you talk about the
compensation for the admins it would be
useful to have both the compensation and
the head counts just to put it in better
context sure and if uh there are admins
specifically related to Grants like you
were suggesting that you want to break
it down between feel free to break it
down those ways so uh you know this way
we won't have to ask for more details
later for certain thank
you and then while you finish writing go
ahead are you done writing I don't want
I okay regarding the unique M um mention
so you said that that that was part of
what built up your endowment is that
accurate now my understanding was that
was what is intended to be used for
scholarships so so and this this goes
back to my time even as state treasur
even before I was State Treasurer so
that
program the New Hampshire New Hampshire
has a 529 plan through Fidelity and um
the dollars that come to the state from
that
plan um for many many years let's say
$100 would come in was much more than
that obviously $70 of that 70% of that
would go to Every college and
university private and public Community
College all of our highered institutions
$70 would be distributed based on
student count New Hampshire student
count to build up an
endowment 30% so $30 would go directly
to the institutions for annual
scholarships that would go right out the
door
so oh my word it's it's probably been
20 could be 25 years now that that
program has been in
place two years ago two years ago I
believe we flipped it so now 30% of the
dollars that come in the door go to the
endowments at all the schools and 70% of
the dollars go straight out to students
so there were two revenue
streams and so over time for the
University system over those 25 years
that's built up to about $90
million in endowment that's in that
endowment that pays out 4 and a half%
per year for the neediest New Hampshire
students and the eligibility criteria is
established by the college savings
commission and that pays out so it's
going to be there in perpetuity that
will pay out for New Hampshire needy New
Hampshire students at all of the
institutions public and private across
the
state can I ask you a question Mr landan
regarding the 15 the is this the related
certainly so um again this so I have
some experience as state treasure I also
currently sit on the college savings
tuition planning committee um
so about $15
million comes into the state that might
be actually a little more than that
right now comes into the state from
Fidelity from it's millions of dollars
in the in the 529 plan under the New
Hampshire unique program there's a fee
that Fidelity pays to the state say it's
$15
million of that $15 million right now
30% goes to so so just to be clear it's
that it's that pot of money that you're
talking about with all the percentages
100 yes okay that that's I was trying to
understand thank you that makes sense to
me back to your endowment payout so
4 half% seems kind of low especially
given that you've had pretty substantial
I assume like everybody else growth in
your underlying Investments so our
assumed rate of return over the long
term is six and a half% and so but you
think about an inflation component so 4
and a
half%
is not unusual for an endowment payout
over the long term because some years we
will achieve more than
62% but in the years when it goes below
that or goes in the red it takes long
time to make up a loss in the market so
that's why it's yes we could we could
achieve 10% or 12% but we don't we
don't calculate the payout based on one
year's um earnings we smooth it to
reduce volatility over the long term and
do you have some statistics on similarly
endowed schools regarding their payouts
and that sort of thing I can absolutely
get that for
you I'll just get it straight from the
horse's mouth
here she just saying I get from about
the sources but I'd rather get it from
you of
course I'm sure she'll help me
thank
you anybody else on okay this is exactly
why I wanted to bring it up because I
know it it comes up often around
endowment so happy to answer any
questions super thank please continue
thank you for your on slide six I just
want to um this is an excerpt from the
business and industry associations one
of its policy priorities for
2025 is to explore poor incentives to
keep New Hampshire students in New
Hampshire and as I mentioned um for the
first time since 2013 our enrollment
actually our New Hampshire enrollment
actually increased in the fall of
24 and at the same time our surrounding
states are dealing with the same thing
we are in all across New England there
are our demographics there are fewer
young people in the pipeline so they're
doubling down trying to keep their
students and take our students at the
same time with with investment and um
you know we we need to continue to
attract equip and retain our students to
drive the workforce of the future here
in New
Hampshire and and on slide seven I want
to get into this a little more and I
talked earlier about that's that's why I
included slide one with section one of
RSA 187a
um it is a public Mission and we're
committed to delivering on that public
Mission the
um as in this fastpaced changing
environment in the future we will need
folks that have education at all
levels High School certificate
Associates Bachelors gradu we will need
people that have education in at all
different different levels and so it's
it's the part in my mind it's the
partnership um that we need to Foster
across business higher ed government K12
to drive that um the honestly that's one
of the things I think about when we have
fewer people in the pipeline and we know
that not just business and industry all
of our employers across the state one of
their biggest concerns as Workforce so
when we think about what we look like 10
years we the state our citizenry 10
years from now in my mind we need to
ensure we have that pipeline for for
Workforce according to the Department of
Business and economic Affairs life
sciences and advanced manufacturing are
real growth areas and the university
system is very much plugged in to um to
those sectors and others and again indic
indicative of the letter letters of
so while we are facing some significant
headwinds and we need to continue to
structures right now the university
system does have a strong balance sheet
and we want to make sure we keep it that
way um and that's how we are able to
make
investments that will and deliver on our
public mission that will benefit the
state and Workforce in the future I just
want to give you a couple of examples
because we have been making those
Advance those Investments with
significant support from the state $35
million over a six-year period in the
capital budget UNH actually I think the
ribbon cutting is this summer um just
completed a $95 million Life Sciences
Spalding uh Life
Sciences building um it was an ex it was
a renovation of of an old the old
Spalding Life Sciences with that $35
million the university system invested
another $60
million that's to ensure that we can
attract students faculty collaborate
with business on Innovative work in the
Life Sciences field well into the
future at Plymouth um Hyde Hall I think
will also be opening maybe in the fall
it's the Innovation and
Entrepreneur Center business for the
North Country um the state supported
through cap with through Capital support
um I think we're up to maybe $5
million University system invested
another $22 million
and just
recently I don't know if folks are
familiar with the Olson Advanced
manufacturing center over at UNH it's
quite the place um the the also at UNH
through Noah the National Oceanic
atmospheric Association um UNH does very
Cutting Edge research with Noah and Noah
um through a grant with Noah there'll be
a facility um Noah facility constructed
at at
un and our board just approved an
additional $9 million
investment to we have part cor um
business partners collocated at the Olen
center it's high Bas based High Advanced
manufacturing and we are going to
construct the facility so that we can
have more corporate Partners research
students are working with these
corporate Partners High School Community
College University students all working
on Advanced manufacturing cuttingedge
Innovative Advanced manufacturing and
that will also be located um with that
Noah building on the UNH campus uh the
these are examples of we know it's
important to our students our faculty
and our state that that we have a
pipeline into that those new and
advancing
Technologies we've already on slide nine
we've already talked about our
enrollment decline the our enrollments
declined 11% during that that fiveyear
period from the income statement I I
walked you through
earlier I already mentioned um that will
have real impacts on our future
Workforce needs and we know I think I
already mentioned for fiscal 26 we need
to take $20 million out of our cost
structure so difficult difficult
decisions we're being worked on right
now um we frankly can't nibble around
the edges anymore we start need we need
to start making some decisions about
what are we not going to do um as as the
um and those those we're developing
now I I just want to point out um we
know we have to make those difficult
decisions we are and we will um we don't
seek State support to avoid making those
difficult decisions and um which is why
I'm not sitting here asking that we need
flat funding we know I well know from my
uh former life life as state treasure
the state is facing some very very
difficult decisions so not anyway I I'll
that representa Dory can you give us
some idea what you're thinking what
areas you're thinking about decreasing
knowing that you have the economic
drivers that you need to have in place
but what what areas are you thinking
about cutting um thank you
representative for the question I'd
rather not get into any specifics right
now um we are um at we are having
conversations about Academic Program
sharing across our institutions so that
if one institution um is no longer going
to offer a certain major or a certain
course that a student could take a class
let's say they're a Plymouth student and
they they Plymouth doesn't have that
program anymore they could take the
class and UNH if that's where we're
offered or Keen to really um leverage
online capabilities to do that
so it's possible to make some decisions
around well we're not going to have this
major or this program at this school
anymore we're going to have it here
we're going to focus on
Specialties we're also
um you know we're we're uh developing
strategies with AI um what how can we
leverage AI to produce more
administrative
work um
so there are a lot of conversations
happening um you know we need to think
about so we have shortterm right we have
a uh actions we need to take quickly so
so our budgets our board um requires
through our budget parameters that um
the university system have a 1%
operating
margin so for those of you that have
worked in business you'll say well
that's not very much a 1% operating
margin really what a 1% operating margin
in my mind is a flat budget with a
little bit of a contingency in it right
um it's just that and the board our
board has said you we need to get to a
place where we're 2 3% operating margin
be because that's what we can use to
then invest in things like
the Ola manufacturing center and the
Life Sciences Center so um right now
because of the headwinds because we
recognize that the state also has has
decisions to make the 1% operating
margin is where we are um but even to
get there with enrollment declining we
need to to um make changes the other
thing we're really drilling into is
facilities our footprint um with fewer
students we don't need the footprint
that we'll need in the long term that's
a longer term play we can't you know
it's it's February we can't change on a
dime and drive a big reduction in
footprint by July but how do we think
about that that comes back to academic
programming if academic programming is
going to change the footprint should
change with it so that's why we're
selling buildings we've demolished
buildings we're getting out of leas
space um but we have to push on that
even
further can you share with us as far as
a manufacturing component is is is
happening who's driving your life
sciences what manufacturer here in in
Hampshire is actually coming to you and
saying I'm going to drop in couple
million bucks here or you know 100
million bucks who is
that well we don't have any private
dollars that have dropped in $100
million um we have we have a very strong
part uh partnership with lonza and and
they have provided some funding for
equipment we also um over at Keen um I'm
I don't know if you're aware so there's
I think there are six companies in the
madok
region forgive me if I get the words
mixed up
Diamond turning
Precision
Optics um believe it or not the world
leader in that equipment being produced
in the manad
region and um Keen state has through
some federal support has um just opened
a diamond the Optics manufacturing lab
and um some of the businesses in the
Mano region have provided the equipment
um and so now there will be a
certificate start with a certificate and
then grow to an undergraduate program as
a pipeline from Keen State into into
industry okay slide
10 um I I tried to anticipate questions
obviously I didn't anticipate them all
because I have some takeaways but um so
recent and ongoing actions from um
Washington um I wanted to just touch on
some how we're monitoring those and what
that's looking like so Dei related we um
are working our general counsel is
working closely with all of our campuses
right there are executive orders
relative to Dei initiatives and there
was also I think it was on February 17th
um it's being called a dear colleague
letter that was um issued by the US
Department of Education to all k12 and
highered and so um relative to um Dei
and hiring and promotions and admissions
I will tell you that the university
system is compliant with law we are our
general council's office is working with
all of our campuses going through
websites our programs over 1,200 federal
grants we're going through the language
we need to again we are compliant with
the law we want to make sure that we
continue to be C compliant with the law
and we are it it's
um you know the the guidance comes out
and then there'll be Court action and so
we're monitoring it and I just want to
make you aware make you aware of that
and then also with um federal grants as
I said the um we have $222 million in
federal direct and indirect federal
dollars coming in in fiscal 24 and well
plus another 22 million
impel as of last
Friday um we had received stop work
orders on four federal grants a total
$700,000 um and then after um I finish
this I got um a word that there was also
a food safety award that won't be
renewed and the New Hampshire Department
of Agriculture made us aware of that um
there was also so why should we
care with if there are significant
reductions in federal indirect cost or
direct cost that could definitely have
an impact on the level of research that
we're conducting it could have an impact
on jobs and Innovation and all of that
so we're monitoring it and again we will
do what everything we need to do to
ensure that we are compliant with
law it's great to hear that could you
not necessarily right now but could you
provide specifics as to what you've
actually done regarding the Dei with
what your general council is working on
what what has he actually accomplished
sure and a question I would have there
is have you simply renamed positions
done things of that nature
rather
than dealing with
the goal of what the administration has
been requesting um no we haven't ramed
anything can let's go to slide 11 I I
wanted to um I wanted to take this head
on because I know it's it's on people's
minds and I want to get any information
for you um that I don't or can't provide
this morning but I know this is top of
mind so I want to talk about
Dei related and what that means and um I
think it's important
that we
[Music]
all the tricky part is defining what is
Dei because I'll tell you across the
university system we spend about $3
million on what we call De in our Dei
offices or Dei related but that
includes services for um students
support services for students with
disabilities student support services
for veterans it includes
required compliance for Title 9 and
Ada and um employment law so when I say
$3
million like what do we Define like what
do I need to parse out how are we going
to Define what is
Dei so
it it's we don't have an office that's
we're going to support services based on
race we don't have an office like that
it's it's an office that provides
different supports to all kinds of
different students I will also say that
all of these any program that we
have is available to all students right
we don't have programs that only you can
participate in this or only you can
participate in that we we do actually
even before The Supreme Court ruling
student versus Harvard I think that that
banned
um race and admissions New Hampshire's
had a law on that for a long time we
don't base admissions on race and and
um even that I was reading the dear
colleague letter that I referred to and
it said um institutions can't have
different housing for different students
or different graduation ceremonies we've
never done anything like that we don't
have separate housing or separate
graduation um Ceremonies for different
types of students so
um I I'll I'll stop there and let let
you folks ask any questions right
Joy can you explain to me naen Petty's
position because this to me looks like
diversity inclusion and so Equity so
naen is the CH her title is Chief
diversity officer at
UNH but under
her work portfolio if you will are all
of these program
the the Civil Rights office that
investigates compliance with Title 9 and
Ada and and employment law also under
her is are are the services
for oh I just looked at this the other
day I think there are five employees for
services for students with disabilities
we have American Sign Language
interpreters we have um special needs
counselors right for for students with
disabilities as well as veterans now
also programs there are student Affinity
groups that anyone can join but there
could be a student affinity group of
different religions a h or
um uh African-Americans anyone can join
those but but student you know will have
there are Affinity groups on campus so
her
portfolio does
include diversity programming But it
more represent
papovich just to continue in the same
line thank you again um under
represented student populations can you
expand on that a little certainly those
those might include students of
color
um that could include LGBT
students um any any unrepresented group
and just to follow up
right at the end of the day support is
good right once somebody's admitted they
got to have the necessary tools to
survive and some of the groups may have
different needs you know first
generation College goers may not have
had the same family support and so on so
right support for underrepresented
student population is one thing
you know are you saying that there is no
impact on the odds of somebody being
admitted to UNH because they belong to
an underrepresented student
population I I would argue that we do
not admit someone to UNH or Plymouth or
Keane because they are a member of an
unrepresented
group well that's to say you're not
admitting them so because that I I hear
you what weight would belonging to an
underrepresented student population what
process again
representative I would argue it has no
weight and and I will also
say
um you know we are not
Harvard we accept if if if you meet um
educational requirements we have a seat
for you we have more capacity than we
need right now
so it it wouldn't matter what group you
belong to we would welcome you to to
institutions another question that
unrelated to students though what about
Staffing that would be against the law
we don't we don't
hire our employees based on whether or
not they're in an
unrepresented group so I I don't know
who this naen person is I'd rather use
her last name I'm guessing that's her
first name but does the chief diversity
officer have any responsibility for
employees or is it is her responsibility
strictly related to students I assume
it's a her sorry if I'm wrong well no um
absolutely there there there would be
some employees because you could have um
you could have accusations of bias or
you could have
employees um who have been harassed or
th you know those types of
Investigations would be under her her
purview I will also say that
um you know during hiring we want to
make sure that's not happening happening
that that people aren't being hired
solely because they belong to one group
or another so her office could get
involved in that that to ensure that we
are
compliant thank
you yeah thinkk you you just happen to
say solely because um solely would be a
heck of a high standard
right but as I asked you earlier solely
is one thing part is
another so I hear the solely can you
comment on any weight that belonging to
again under represented employee
populations may have in hiring
decisions I don't believe that's the
case representative but I will go back
and ask that question I don't believe
that's the case thank you um and a
one of the practices that I read and I
will say that I have I'm not aware of
whether this is the case with the UNH
system or not is that certain
universities seem to consider that uh
Dei was so important that any new
employee had to agree with di principles
to get hired and sign a statement or
affirm a commitment to those standards
could you comment on whether UNH has any
such requirement where an employee has
to agree to certain beliefs to get a job
no that is not the case I will say under
the so we
just in December we went to a new HR
Finance system under the old
system UNH would have in the job posting
that an um an applicant was to complete
a diversity state
statement that the you know H how do you
Embrace inclusion of all people that
that type of thing in the new system
that is not that is no longer hardwired
into a uh that is no longer part of an a
job posting at
UNH I appreciate the evolution into a
better
Direction so is it obviously being
removed from the list of prerequisites
is good
is it something that still still may get
asked or talked about during interviews
or in the process of
hiring I I don't believe so I I suppose
if a hiring
manager thought that was important uh
inclusion
uh that that might be used and if that
happens is that documented that it was
yes I don't know that would yes I
appreciate it and look I I know that
some of these questions may involve
information you may not have at your
fingertips so I appreciate that you're
giving me the best information you have
right now but please if you come across
in you know data later that indicate
that some of this may be slightly
different than what you can recall right
now please uh don't wait for further
questions from us just let us know if
you become aware of any changes of on
that Absa absolutely repres Murray thank
you can we go back to some of the
questions on
enrollment um can you uh you had a small
increase um recently and but overall
there's been the decline can you par out
the difference between undergraduate and
graduate with the numbers you're here
are they all undergraduate students
because I'd be curious to see if there's
an increase in graduate students who are
coming graduate has has um um across the
system has remained fairly flat the
reason being um Plymouth State used to
have so it's it's increased at UNH but
it's come down intentionally at Plymouth
State Plymouth State used to have a
um quite a few uh graduate students and
but um it was
not I know our entire being isn't about
making money but it wasn't generating
dollars for Plymouth and so over time
Plymouth has reduced its graduate
programs so as a system we've remained
fairly St we have remained stable on The
Graduate
side represent
envelops thank you Mr chair and thank
you uh for um being here today and
sharing some more information with us um
I'm just a little bit concerned about U
the federal grants and the current
um I guess you would call it executive
order directives that um the indirect
Grant dollars might be capped um for
instance I've had this conversation with
private institution in my district uh
about their concern um and they were
able to calculate um the type of funding
that they might lose if the indirect cap
were to go into place I'm just wondering
if usnh has also calculated the loss and
if you can quantify that for us sure now
the
um I don't think this was an executive
order I I believe it was a letter from
the NIH I think you're right ni is
National Institutes of Health and so we
calculated on the NIH it would be about
a million dollar loss the university
system doesn't have big big dollars with
the NIH like probably Dartmouth does um
but of the amounts that we receive from
the National Institute of instit NIH um
it would be about a million dollars of
indirect
cost that would come from but it you
so okay um one moment repres Kelly
sorry thank you thank you for being here
today um on slide eight you talk about
the relationship between UNH and Noah so
I'm wondering if there do you foresee
any uh disruption in that relationship
or harm being done from what's
being done so no
um on March as of March 3D we have not
received that there will be um any
significant pullback of of Noah dollars
and and the university does have it's
another um
you know UNH is one of the world leaders
in Ocean mapping working with um with
Noah but no we aren't aware at this time
any you're good go ahead thank you sorry
my last slide is um slide 12 again uh I
mentioned earlier highed is changing
um it it's a tough business here in New
England um but the mission is second to
none it's important that um we partner
to deliver on the the future needs of of
our state's Workforce and our state's
economy and our quality of life um there
will be difficult there are and will be
more difficult decisions um in the
future and again we respectfully request
that the governor's recommended funding
level of that um 8% reduction be be held
for the University system and that it
not be reduced any further and and just
um I provide we provided um some
appendix slides and those we already
provide those were from the orientation
you the the committee had asked for
followup at the orientation we sent that
material to Mickey right after the
meeting but I thought I'd include those
here um for your information and I'll
will also provide this um you know
electronically to Mickey so that that
you have it you don't have to have a
hard
copy thank
you representative Murray hold on yeah
just one more thing the um the 95
million for 2025 the anticipated is how
close to that is that real um I know
we're still in the middle I know it's
anticipated um but my question is
there's just a what about three and a
half million difference between that and
the request for this year um I would go
on the record to say that I would love
to see us come up with the 95 million um
that you are anticipating in 2025 just
my view on the support for the
University system in
2025 yeah the anticipated is is that the
right way isn't that this year I I yes I
I haven't heard it's being reduced for
2025 yeah so that 20 that 20 fiscal 25
95 million that's what's currently
budgeted already appropriated right I
haven't heard that's being reduced no
but it's not no no but I would like to
see the next bium support that amount to
continue huh 26 27 yes I would like to
see 26 we would very much sure very much
like to see the flat funding but but
again we also acknowledge that you know
I I understand the lay of the land but
that would be terrific that's you know
I'm just want to to for the record put
that out there that I would like to see
the flat funding continue thank you
representative papovich thank you Mr
chair while we are in the for the record
territory a couple of topics I wanted to
briefly address not as much questions
but thoughts I'd like to share with you
to understand at least where I'm coming
from right I appreciate the effort to
keep tuition flat we've been doing that
for a long time problem is that if you
keep it flat forever it gets closer and
closer to free every year I mean
technically this $100 we make every
every year used to be 6 months of wages
and now it's 27 cents a day of course
we're talking a couple of you know a few
more years than we kept to ising flat
but the point is I understand that we
needed to do that for a while to become
more competitive with other states I
just want to State on the record that
this type of policy cannot be sustained
permanently and there are reasons why we
are looking to adjust it and whatnot in
reasonable ways and keeping an eye to
all those factors so again in the for
the record territory the other for the
comment is in regards to your
endowment I completely agree that you
need to have the discipline to continue
to grow it I I I would just suggest that
you keep in mind that we should
continuously reexamine the expected
growth rates versus the amount of uh
money we are planning to you know draw
out of the endowment because we need to
balance the focus on growth with the
need to serve our current students there
are other colleges privates that have
gone on a rather ridiculous path where
they accumulated in their endowments
more money than they need to pay for the
tuition of every student that will ever
attend the college and they keep asking
for more endowments I'm not saying you
are planning to go in that direction I'm
just saying that we really need to find
that middle ground between those two and
I would really appreciate it if you guys
continued looking at it without us
needing to remind you and pro you about
it I know that you do but you know it's
important again for certain things to be
said on the record as as far as I'm
concerned and I'm done in slightly less
than probably the forecasted time so
thank
you other
questions um so a couple
more probably you get back to what kind
of things um how much State support from
our capital budget has the universe
received over the past five years on on
an annual basis and how about State
contracts over that same period of
time and I'm
looking at the state the the budget
document here the one page thing is it
possible to get something that's kind of
in between this and the state our state
budget in terms of detail something a
little more detailed than this but
doesn't have to be quite what the
governor provided and ideally as an
actual spreadsheet I mean
a spreadsheet document not as something
that looks like a
spreadsheet would be great go
ahead so more more detail than we
provided not as much detail is yeah I
again I'm leaving to your judgment but
something maybe by department but you
know something
between what this is and what the state
provides now granted the state is very
detailed so I'm not looking for that
right but something that maybe gives
better idea of what's going on inside
the institution as opposed to this is
kind of like a balance sheet for a COR
top Corporation if you go to slide
so you'd like to see by department at
each
institution I will give you the
flexibility to decide how you want to do
it okay okay but clearly you are as a
former Treasurer former everything
you've done you're well aware of ranges
of detail that could be divided in a
budget and maybe somewhere between
other questions no we good at the risk
of eating into my friend we'll let her
we'll let her go along too um I usually
like to um recap so I'm not missing
anything that that the committee has
asked for so we are going to get
administrative salary administrative
salaries over the that that fiveyear
change 19 to 24 we're going to break it
out by Grant versus non-grant and per
student and as compensation as well as
headcount okay um we're also going to
provide um Benchmark of a endowment
payout rates with peer
institutions um we're going I'm going to
check with General Counsel on what's
actually been done related to the work
that that they are doing with our
campuses on grants and websites and
programs um I'm going to
confirm that we're not hiring employees
based on what group they belong to
whether partially or
solely um okay hang on I got the flat
tuition endowment payout we talked about
um State
support from on the capital side over
the P why don't we go six years because
that's the bi anyal that'll be three by
Anum more the marrier state
contracts and more detail
budget any other items that she missed
sound pretty thorough to me great thank
you both very much appreciate thank you
thank you and with that I think I am
supposed to close the hearing at 11:04
a.m. and ask up open the hearing
for uh
chop been post
okay okay no that that's fine I just
want to make sure I didn't miss
something
whenever you're ready please introduce
yourselves and go
forward good morning Mark Rubenstein
Chancellor of the community college
system my
colleague Shannon Reed director of
government Affairs and Communications
should be able to pull that toward
yourself a lot of wire hanging out this
side is this is this better
sorry there you go uh Shannon Reed
director of government Affairs and
Communications for the community college
system
good morning we appreciate the
committee's time this morning we were
here within the last few weeks focused a
lot of that conversation on Mission the
core work that we do in serving students
from our early college and Workforce
programs to our degree and certificate
programs we're here today primarily to
talk about finance and we'll touch on
anything else that the committee would
like to hear about so move relatively
quickly through the
three the governor aot frankly was very
kind to us in the budget particularly in
the context that we know other state
agencies other other entities faced in
the midst of fiscal challenges for the
state but did want to start out just by
uh addressing something that I think has
been at least a little bit misunder
stood at least by some in the
media um in comparing the current bium
2425 with the governor's proposal for
2627 on paper it looks like a
significant increase to be honest we'd
be grateful to have just held even but
but one of the things that that's
important to note about the current bium
that we're in is that Governor sonunu
put significant funding in House Bill 2
that isn't necessarily Apples to Apples
when you account for funding for
Workforce early college and for a
promise program that's a total of about
$10 million that showed up in House Bill
2 in the last panium that's now built
fully into Governor aot's proposed House
Bill one budget so it's still about a
million and a half net favorable and
again in the challenging Financial
circumstances the state has we're we're
grateful but I do want to I did want to
address what I think is at least some
confusion that some in the media have
have discerned in looking at the
governor's
budget one of the best things about
having good colleagues is that you've
got a coach and Angel on your shoulder
remind you what you should do while
you're here um I I I'll note that that a
couple of layers of detail in Governor
sununu's budget one thing that did find
its way into house bill one was a
million and a quarter each year to
support tuition assistance for students
pursuing early childhood
education the the argument at the time
that we made was that there are a number
of Grant programs to support early
childhood education students but they
were a patchwork and they left a lot of
gaps and in discussing this with our
faculty who teach in those programs what
they said is when those grants don't
cover something students typically step
back compensation in that field is not
great and so for students to incur the
expense or the debt that comes with
borrowing for that was a barrier
governor sonunu was kind enough to put
that in and when we spoke with Governor
aot earlier what we had said is that if
our budget could be held flat we would
anticipate that we would treat that same
million and a quarter a year to be
available for Early Child education we
we continue to think that that's a
worthwhile investment for the
state u a couple of the other pieces can
I just to clarify something so are you
suggesting that the governor's budget is
flat with your current
budget and I'm just looking at the topl
line numbers here that's why I'm asking
that
question net of things that were either
in house bill one or two I think we're
about 1.5 million up over the
bium maybe I misunderstand your
spreadsheet here but it looks like
you're including all of hb2 and hb1 and
everything am I miss reading right what
what I saying is that in Governor
sununu's budget much of this was in
House Bill 2 in Governor aot's proposed
budget it's all in house bill one so
when you look at just House Bill one
across the two Bia you end up with what
looks like a significant difference of
about $10 million most of that is moving
things that had been in House Bill 2
into house bill one okay maybe I
misunderstanding what you're displaying
here so we're we're on slide three
correct correct and across the top you
see numbers like 66 million 63 million
for the current Bion name and then 69
and 70 and then down below under the 24
actual 25 adjusted authorized you see
the things I think you're referring to
that are in hb2 are those not included
in your sums at the top is that what
you're telling me no what I'm in in
house in in the current bium those were
not I'm if I could explain maybe a
slightly different way um in the the two
left-hand columns the blue shaded
columns FY 24 and FY 25 there's a house
one number which is the Topline number
and to that was
added the the amounts that are kind of
below where it says houseal 2 included
in basically the third row so if you
took all those and put and and added
them into the Topline number they would
be closer to what you see as a topl line
number in FY 26 and 27 so the hb2
numbers even though they're displayed
here at the bottom you did not include
them in the top line number
okay my apology one more good reason to
have a teammate with you
yeah so um just moving on then if there
were no additional questions just to
note that on slide four uh both the
Early College proposal and the math
learning communities are actually
subjects of separate legislation that's
house on Slide Five House Bill
25 at this point we have uh
$700,000 in the governor's budget
specifically for being able to relocate
a welding program currently from a
facility that we are leasing in
Rochester to the camp the Great Bay
Community College's permanent location
in at peas um we had we had requested
about $17 million for a range of of
things
critical maintenance Energy Systems it
Renovations the first thing you
mentioned doesn't seem to appear here
you mentioned something in hb1 in the
governor's budget $700,000 for
something that's um we included SL five
which is about house 25 which I know
isn't specifically the purview of this
committee y but the point the point is
to say that in hille 25 we currently
have
an appropriation of
$700,000 for the the welding purpose
that the chancellor described which is
not here correct which which is not here
because it wasn't it wasn't actually one
of our original requests it's something
that came up kind of later in the
process um but none of the capital funds
that we had actually requested back last
fall when this process starts were
funded in hospit 25 so the point of that
is that we will need to find a way to
support our it infrastructure upgrade
needs our critical
maintenance Capital maintenance um and
whatever other Capital work we need to
do U we'll need to find ways to do that
without using Capital funds so this is
going to be a a a draw in one way or
another on our operating budget for the
next bayum so requested 17 million
didn't receive it did not receive any of
that 17 million receive $700,000 for
unrelated yes items thank you you you
may know the capital budget uh timetable
starts quite early well in advance of
the the budget year so the the welding
issue is something that came up after we
had developed and submitted our capital
budget request we brought it forward in
the governor's phase and it was
something that the governor um decided
to include in the capital budget but
nothing else that we
requested um had been included in the
governor's capital
budget thank you thank
you um I'll I'll just move to slide
seven um and and just briefly as I said
we're primarily here to talk about
Finance but does not hurt to to uh share
reminder of what our focus is these are
credentials for The Last 5 Years and
still work in progress for the current
year um shows a high concentration of
our programs in healthc care in
particular as well as transfer Focus
programs in Liberal Arts sciences and
business and then a range of other
programs supporting manufacturing
construction and so forth so just wanted
to highlight the the landscape there
this does not include our
apprenticeships nor does it include our
boot camps many of which have a
particular focus in advanced and
precision
manufacturing so turn turning to slide
eight and
finances this is general fund
appropriation uh House Bill one
essentially over the last three by any
including the one we're currently in and
as as I've said before grateful for what
has been uh growth and support from the
state on behalf of our
students you'll note in particular that
the last bium uh significant uptick from
2223 into
2425 specifically the request that we
had made to help us keep tuition flat
for students the state has been an
extraordinary partner for the community
college system for more than a decade
and has allowed us to keep tuition
virtually flat through that entire time
we are still among the most expensive
Community College systems in the country
but we haven't lost ground and in fact
over time as the federal government has
invested more in pel Grants a student
who is now fully pel eligible can cover
the cost of the community college system
with that Grant something that wasn't
true a decade ago when that student
would have still needed to find $2,000 a
year to pay 430 credits so we're
grateful for
that as you shift to the next slide
slide nine before you leave that just
tell us what a restricted ECE is the
orange bars that's the early childhood
education that one and a quarter off the
top thank you you're welcome so a as I
shift to slide nine which shows the
pattern of tuition fees the first thing
you'll notice from 20 to 21 is that
sharp
downturn through the p pmic community
colleges across the country in the two
years where the pandemic was most
evident had about an 18% drop in
enrollment our students who are often
again are demographic typically working
adults parents who suddenly became the
homeschooled Zoom parent in the home
classroom all of those reasons our
enrollment fell during that time so
tuition Revenue fell over time what
you'll see what might look like
relatively flat tuition please keep in
mind that this is also a product of the
state having made an investment to allow
us to keep tuition flat so that even as
enrollment was growing it was being
absorbed no additional cost to students
in the last two years we've seen 3 and
4% year-over-year growth is not
necessarily reflected in the tuition but
it is an illustration of the way supply
and demand is supposed to work by
keeping costs and more affordable for
students it's allowed more students to
progress um and the 25 figure is still
preliminary we expect that there'll be
more growth again reflecting
year-over-year increase in enrollment
flat slide 10 just some illustrations of
the key elements of non-tuition Revenue
uh you'll notice in particular um
the gry bar's non-credit activity this
is an area where Governor sonunu made an
investment where Governor aot has
proposed to make an investment what
you'll see is we're starting to see the
return on that investment notably in the
current year these are non-credit
training programs in health care and
Manufacturing in areas where seed money
made available from the state for those
programs has allowed us to deliver them
um and somewhat entrepreneurial asking
each of the campuses to figure out what
the needs were in their region and then
to deliver programs tailor to Employers
areas slide 11 personnel expenses slow
down um what happened to
Grants
so the the anomaly that you're seeing is
21 and 22 pandemic era significant
infusions of federal money specifically
responding to the pandemic for lost
Revenue I believe turned to coo
Fields so th those funds were available
for those two years to offset the Lost
revenue and then have
dissipated no understand what they are
but it looks like they more than offset
your loss Revenue that
they they did Banner years there it's
it's t it's lost tuition but it's also
lost auxiliary Revenue so it it it was a
c it was a formula calculated to account
for what we actually lost we also were
able to use um this Federal funding to
invest in um technology that we needed
to deliver more of our instruction
online given the pandemic and so much of
our instruction is uh very difficult to
deliver online as you can imagine it's
Hands-On it's lab laboratory based so um
we we receive funding that enabled us to
account for some less Revenue but also
to invest in enhanced online learning
technology that still serves us today as
we still have a significant part of our
enrollment accessing Us online Pap just
to add a little bit of color to this
discussion the arpa whatever other
Federal acronym you want to call them by
the funds where meant to be a
replacement for loss Revenue but the
entities receiving it were only required
to match that to revenue losses above a
certain level of funding any entity that
receives funds under that deadline just
took the money and was told it doesn't
matter if we gave you more than what you
lost it is what it is we are not
required to account for it you can just
keep the whole thing so I'm assuming
that in the case of ccsnh they got more
in arpa than the loss Revenue but you
know they
had the ability to keep that funds and
again you as you were saying they used
them to fund certain longer term
liabilities they were concerned about
all of which would be squarely within
the scope of the arpa funds and frankly
I would rather see you guys use that
U you know unexpected Fortune to deal
with long-term concerns rather than blow
it on operational expenses and then not
have that so I appreciate that but I
didn't want to provide that color
because not everybody in the room may
you know have the uh background and it
should be on the record thank you thank
you and could you also explain other
operating costs and you don't have any
projections here for 26 and
27 under operating revenue or
expense um I'm are we still on slide
10 or did I get under the wrong slide
operating it's not a trick
question sorry about that Scott Field's
Chief Operating Officer the for the
system when you had just uh said other
operating you said expense and I think
that's where the confusion came from so
this other operating Revenue other
operating that's exactly I apologize
wrong word no that's okay so I'm sorry
what was the question what is it oh what
oh it includes a number of different
things if you think of uh bookstore
commissions interest uh Revenue things
of that nature so it's a lot of smaller
buckets that are put into one for the
sake of the chart to for clarity so did
great in
24 what happened in
25 in and do you expect it to go back up
in 26 27 I don't see any numbers here
you know any projections for the coming
by any so we're in the middle of our
budget creation process for 26 and 27 so
we don't have forecasts yet for the
upcoming bium that said if we look at um
there was a significant increase in
unrealized gains in 24 that go into this
number as well as part of our as in
stock market type gains you we have yes
we have funds that are invested to
offset um operating cost as well as look
at long-term liabilities okay that's
great so you say you're in the middle of
your budgeting
correct yes yes this is what we talking
about though isn't it
yes so you must have some Revenue
projections or you must be be able to
divide those to us we're working with
the colleges as they develop their
enrollment projections for the 2627 bium
so as they go through that process we
look at non-credit Revenue we look at um
other operating income like interest uh
interest revenue from our investments
pulling that all together we're actually
working towards getting data together to
bring to our board
in April okay thank you repres while you
are here thank you um I did want to come
back to one of my uh favorite topics
which is that I really appreciate
getting the you know numbers going from
one year to the other but it would be
nice when we are provided with those
variations if without having to ask next
time we'd get a basic variance analysis
just color commentary on exactly what
you are asked about hey how come that
the other operating went from three to
five and then now to four right I mean
this type of stuff honestly I know that
this may not have been the way things
were done in the past
but it seems like a very basic type of
document to have that would be
appreciated going forward and trust me
I'm asking this of everyone it's not you
the other thing too and I I'm trying to
understand right cuz what the chairman
Earth was saying earlier I'm trying to
understand the timing of your forecasts
right
because I don't know how I budget if I
don't have a revenue budget versus the
you know expenditures budget right so
we're trying to
finalize all the state side of the
budgets in what a month
plus it seems to be difficult to do that
without having any inkling of what the
forecast may be for your you know
operate operating years I understand
that forecast get refined with new data
all the time but you should be able to
provide provide some sort of whatever
internal forecast you have even
understanding it may not be as great as
you may have it so we'd appreciate it if
you'd look into just giving us some
insight into how you see that going with
the information you have right now
because at the end of the day we have
what one more month something to
finalize this for us so we cannot wait
for it to be perfect no understood and I
think part of as we're going through our
process internally with some of the
variability from what the state may come
back with that means a lot to us we more
than 50% of our gross revenue comes from
the state that you know
small heel back could mean a significant
operational change for some of our
colleges so we I think we were waiting
for some of that to come through as we
then finalized it if that's something
were to change now I'm confused I was
talking about the forecast on
revenues not about the budget the
costs we will be back with with what you
requested we'll bring you preliminary
forecasts it would be much appreciated
again understanding they're not fully
finalized and all forecasts are subject
to being an educated guest and all that
you thank you proceed okay so on on
slide 11 personnel expenses the the the
notable piece of analysis here that
that's perhaps
helpful this includes Grant funded
positions and although our grant
portfolio is somewhat smaller than the
University Systems by an order of
magnitude um in 2015 we had two Grant
funded positions uh in 20202 it was 16
it's currently
41 so we've had a significant growth in
Grant funded positions primarily
supporting our apprenticeship New
Hampshire work through the US Department
of Labor that in fact probably pushes up
the Personnel lines that otherwise would
be down over a period of
time it might be nice if you could
actually break those out then we will
bring
that um slide 12 facilities expense just
illustration of what we've been uh
investing in annually uh for maintenance
and uh transfers of equipment over
5,000 our board over the last few years
has expressed an interest in seeing each
of the colleges and the system begin to
elevate the pace at which we're
investing in that simultaneously as you
heard from my counterpart Chancellor
preventure we've been evaluating our
foot our footprint trying to figure out
what physical infrastructure we actually
need for the future versus things that
we've we've had for years that may no
purpose um and then slide one represent
Murray I'm sorry I just what's the
equipment so transfers of equipment
is if they come in for equipment yeah
for equipment as they come in over a
certain dollar amount that then transfer
it it's just it's our internal language
sorry it's it's then transferred into uh
Capital asset areas within our budget
so it's things that could I'm sorry go
ahead I still don't know what that means
oh equipment could be anything from uh
an air handler unit HVAC it could be uh
facilities equipment to front end loader
things of that nature so it could be
it's it's all encompassing of what could
be purchased my I'm not doing a good job
of explaining so it's transferring an
additional cost of what something you
bought something at costom War so you
have to transfer money in order to pay
for that thing I'm still do you know
well it it's differentiating small
purchases from larger purchases
something above $5,000 we categorize
differently just for budgeting purposes
and then gets capitalized over
time okay so so it's the way they
account for it yes when they're when
they're buying small stuff they can
expense it when they're buying big stuff
they've got to capitalize it or amortize
it in the case of software thank
you you're welcome glad I got offer some
help not only
questions and then SL slide 13 just a
categorization of major operating
expenses other than personnel and and
Facilities over time U as you can see
there's a large bucket that's described
as other operating expense so going back
to a previous slide in the question that
came uh fortunately Co Fields was wise
enough to anticipate the question and
has described what mostly is comprised
bucket but there's no sub buckets in
there that are also substantially Rel
you know I mean well the other ones like
for instance your financial expenses you
know a relatively small bucket are there
a bunch of financial expense type things
in the big bucket that could be broken
out or is it really just a bunch of
random things so again the the second
bullet on the slide says that roughly
50% is attributable to Consumer
consumable lab supplies office supplies
and minor equipment and some so yes to
answer your question there are sub
buckets within the other expense
category if you were to break them all
out they would look much smaller like
much smaller than financial they'
probably be about the same size and the
so in respect to the landscape of the
the sheet we put them all to I put them
all together to just make it easier I
can certainly provide that information
broken out if the committee would like
spreadsheet would be amazing oh there
overview questions from the
committee is that a note or is that you
want
okay uh representative Murray yeah uh
thank you um just you touched on this
before but um it's a area where it pulls
at my heart a little bit here um I
really support you know your early the
training for early childhood education
as well as the training for nursing um I
get stuck uh when salaries are still not
they're not paid they go through all
this and I really appreciate that they
can do this without going into debt but
then they go out into the world and
they're not earning a livable wage and I
know there's really nothing you can do
about that except advocate for it but
it's a frustration for me to train
people to do something and then we have
a culture a society that doesn't value
it enough to give them a livable wage so
just my being my crank for the
day you always need at least
one other rubs and pack and fups uh
thank you Mr chair this might actually
be from Mickey um I'm looking at the hb2
Dual and concurrent enrollment
program um Section 1 of hb2 on page 46 I
remember our last discussion was that um
if HB 193 had passed that we could
possibly take this out of
hb2 um even though there is no fiscal
impact um and I know it did pass the
house I believe with Amendment on
February 13th I'm just wondering does
the house position is that enough for us
to take it out or does it stay how does
that
work so that we we had talked about this
before with a couple other
um Provisions that it's been the
prerogative of Finance to pass a piece
of legislation as part of House Bill 2
even though there is a separate bill in
the case of this one um you can ask the
department or excuse me the uh community
college system what their thoughts are
on that bill surviving on its own my
sense is you probably could take it out
of House Bill 2 since there is a another
piece of legislation uh in the process
and since that does not have a direct
impact to the amount they appropriating
but I'll defer to to
them I think as long as that language
makes it over the Finish Line One Way Or
Another We're okay with it happening
either
way reprenda Murray it it did pass I
think overwhelmingly didn't it so I
think the only concern is if the Senate
might do something and should we hang on
to it until we know what the Senate
does I mean based
on my experience going through this
process there's there's a lot that
happens between now and the end of
Committee of conference so I think
keeping the language alive maybe in a
idea other
questions oh well thank you very much
appreciate the committee's time and
realize you have hard choices and
decisions to make they're grateful for
whatever level of support you can
sustain for us so thank you we
appreciate your time very much as well
thank
you and with that I'll close the hearing
on my hearing is the wrong way
11:35 and then do we need anything else
to any other committee conversations
before we all depart for a wonderful
lunch okay so I I will private word two
questions sure okay I will close the
hearing um finance division two at what
11:35
e
so being 115 will'll open the finance
division 2 meeting with the fish and
game folks um please come on up and
before we get started I'm going to ask
Mr landran to explain a note he sent us
regarding the uh fishing game fund
Surplus
statement so the document that I just
want to just make everyone aware of I
had provided to the committee on the 18
uh it's just the fishing game fund it's
a surplus statement document it's kind
of a snapshot in time basically your
starting point so um presented or in the
Shaded columns is the governor's
recommended budget and then in the
unshaded columns would be kind of where
we are with division two as you start
your
work uh most everything is the same here
your starting point is the governor's
recommended budget of course the only
differences I'll point out is on line
three in fiscal year 20 5 the house Ways
and Means Revenue estimates were
$200,000 more than the governor's so
it's 13.9 instead of 13.7
million and then the other key
difference is if you go down to line 10
uh there's a
$397,000 uh warrant a transfer from
Surplus that fishing game initiated uh
that fiscal approved that occurred uh
presumably in the time between the
governor putting its budget together
until now so we just accounted for that
everything else is the same so if you
follow a beginning balance of 13.2
million which is an unaudited number at
the end of fiscal 24 the act for late
we've talked about that carrying the
estimated revenues as well as what is in
the budget for fishing game forward all
the way till the end of 27 you see after
the Gap adjustment um at the end of the
year there's about $1.4 million
remaining so the balance goes from about
million so regarding that transfer that
was a transfer from General funds into
the fishing no from fishing game Surplus
to their to spend oh that's how they
operate they have to actually okay yeah
so that they are bound fishing game is
bound to what is appropriated in the
budget in host Bill one every year what
they can spend but there is a mechanism
for them to come to fiscal to draw from
their fishing game Surplus to be able to
spend it and that's what that item was
so in a budget where spending from their
Surplus but does just get transferred
into the
start uh so you're you're actually
appropriating so if you look at line
seven that that's their Appropriations
Surplus from un from from revenue they
just their unrestricted re yeah these
are just uh unrestricted fishing game
fund Appropriations so this is their
authorization to spend so line seven uh
indicates what they're authorized to
spend the revenue is is calcul or is uh
captured up top in line three if they
want to spend something so let's look at
line 7 for instance if you look at
fiscal 26 the governor's recommended
budget is 19.5 million if they need to
spend more than that they would have to
draw from Surplus from their
undesignated Surplus increasing that 195
to some other number whatever they ask
to spend and so did fiscal Grant the
397,000 yes that was approved by fiscal
yeah thank you okay
um I'd like to to in introduce
yourselves as well but also as I'm not
sure if Mr L explain to you or not but
if you could go pretty quick you have a
great slide deck which is fantastic but
we're hoping to actually go through the
um the line by line of of your budget so
if you could maybe give us a a fairly
rapid overview of your slide deck and
then we could start going through the
actual budget that would be
possible and and please introduce
yourselves and go
ahead yes uh good afternoon and uh thank
you for for having us uh chairman and
committee members uh my name is
Stephanie simmi I'll brag a little I am
proud director of uh New Hampshire
fishing game I have with me Kathy leonte
who is our chief of business operations
and our chief fiscal officer um the
slide deck that you see before you last
time we met the committee had quite a
few variety questions for us a few of
which we answered uh right away with a
few items but uh some of them we uh
brought forward in this slide deck today
so the presentation today will address
some of those questions initially and
also some of the other current topics um
with that being said and the
understanding that we want to get
through this so we can go line by line
through the budget uh we'll get started
we'll start off with the mission
statement of the agency our agency is
the guardian of New Hampshire's fish uh
wildlife and Marine Resources uh we work
in partnership with the public to
conserve manage and protect these
resources and their habitats across the
state uh we work with Partners to inform
and educate uh New Hampshire residents
and visitors about the resources and we
provide the public with opportunities to
use and appreciate those
resources but what does that really all
mean I just wanted to share with you a
little bit about what we really do we
average over 180 permanent um employees
at any one time we have a approximately
40 conservation officers in enforcing
fish and game laws across the state 38
of them are in the field four of them
are administrative uh positions we work
with an 11 member commission Fishing
Game Commission uh we've been in
existence as I bragged last time for 160
years um we also manage
124 uh Wildlife Management areas to
conserve wildlife and their habitat we
own over 60,000 acres of land we have
160 buildings that we have to maintain
including our headquarters and our four
Regional Offices and F six fish
hatcheries uh we're comprised of seven
different divisions and um we also do uh
boat access sites which we have 130 of
those we have 130 dams and seven fish
ladders that we manage and oversee um
you know if you weren't aware we have
over 500 different Wildlife species in
the state so it's quite a task to manage
those our n non-game program alone
manages uh over 400 species and 169 of
those are designated as species of
greatest concern in our state our
Outreach and Education team they host
over 180 students at the Barry
Conservation Camp uh we have our coming
up soon to discover a wild New Hampshire
day which is in April uh we host over
8,000 people at that event we have a
160,000 followers on all of our social
media accounts so we're out there trying
to reach uh all kinds of folks and
working in 28 different types of
habitats in the granite state and
supporting the granite state natural
resources as best as we can um so I I I
hope that gives you a little bit better
picture of what it means to conserve and
inform and provide public
opportunities um you did ask us so I'm
going to go to the next page which is
the agency submission and the governor's
budget you did ask us to uh address
those points you will see the most uh
probably prominent things in the
governor's budget that affect us are the
most programs and positions did remain
the same throughout the budget and our
our requests however one program the
environmental review program is proposed
to be moved to dep Department of
Environmental Services in the trailer
bill um another thing you might see is
that U the conservation law enforcement
program our general funds that we
requested were not allotted or not
appropriate in that trailer Bill and it
affects our conservation law enforcement
program uh you'll also see that we're
estim ated to utilize lapses in our
unrestricted fishing game fund um
anticipated by the governor's office to
make up the differences and close the
gap uh what that will do obviously is
give us a close to the bottom line at
the end of the
bium um but it is important to note that
uh you know throughout this process the
agency though I wasn't here when we
first built our first uh budget we set
forth to meet the governor's office
requests of uh the general funds and and
reducing those we did that initially and
then of course we have uh these
additional um changes or alterations
that will affect us moving forward I do
when I arrived I did see that we had
some prioritized needs that may not have
been included U I felt like those were
the IT issues the retirement issue the
environmental review program itself and
the employee uh Statewide raises all of
which were being addressed in various
other um components either in an hb2 or
through uh some proposed legislation um
of course all of those things are in
flux at this point things are changing
quickly and daily but uh those are the
primary differences I think if you want
to compare our our proposed budget to
the proposed trailer bill that's what we
see as significant points to discuss at
this point I because we'll be getting
into our revenues restricted and
unrestricted I'd like to turn it over to
Kathy because she's definitely knows
more about this stuff than I do and
she's been here and she has the history
to provide the background if you have
questions okay you don't need to provide
quite so much detail so we can get
through this otherwise we're going to be
here longer than we anticipated in order
okay hi um so there are two different
revenues in the fishing game fund there
are unrestricted revenues and restricted
and restricted are just just that they
are for specific programs and purposes
and when we talk about what is in the
dedicated funds which is restricted
revenues and how we can utilize
those in statute they are very specific
for the income and expenditures of those
revenues unrestricted revenues pay for
all other components of the department
that do not have a restricted component
the unrestricted revenues are where we
have the problem restricted revenues
remain
healthy so I wanted to go over some
discussion points from our meeting on
February 3D that we had with you many of
you had questions although you just said
time is of the essence um so I will not
go into the detail of what I have on the
slides but you did ask what are our pots
of unrestricted revenues and what makes
that up we have 13 individual ual
categories of revenues that make up the
unrestricted fishing game fund and
there's a little description right next
to that
title that I won't go
over unless you have questions after
okay what are our dedicated funds we
have 16 dedicated accounts within our
operating budget the table is on the
next slide in addition we also have the
lifetime license account which is held
at treasury when someone purchases a
lifetime license those funds go into the
lifetime license account which is held
at Treasury and through statute we
receive a portion of that it's 9% of the
principal
balance on an annual
basis that account right now has
slightly over $3 million in
it so the next page is a listing of all
of our 16 dedicated accounts including
the accounting unit the description the
RSA the balance forward into the current
fiscal year which is the unobligated
cash in that account the balance forward
for encumbrances the total of which is
at the final column of the total balance
forward of 9.3 million now even though
it looks as though there could be some
significant balances in these accounts
that's just what's unobligated on paper
the program staff who uh manage these
accounts have priority listings of
projects and contracts that are all
inhouse being reviewed and will be
future the other question you asked is
where is New Hampshire and compared to
other states in license fees so that
chart actually um these figures are from
2025 and I have highlighted New
Hampshire in yellow which indicates the
number of the six New England states of
where we rank as far as what our license
fees
are I will keep
moving what have the licensed Revenue
Trends looked like for the past few
years this is a chart for our license
revenue from fiscal year 2016 to 24 and
as you can see there's a bump in 2020
and 2021 that is due to covid when we
bumped right up we skewed right up and
made a nice little hill we are leveling
out at this point in time I do not see a
downward Trend at any point in the
out the next slide is what has been the
history of general funds into fishing
game
um we received our first transfer from
the general fund in
2014 from 14
through 17 they were actual transfers in
hb2 directly into the fishing game fund
they were not part of our budget from
fiscal year 18 through the current
fiscal year
25 they are actual revenues within the
conservation law enforcement accounting
unit
7887 and that was a decision that came
to between the then director Glenn
Norman do and the then Governor Maggie
Hassen to make the general funds coming
into the fishing game department more
transparent and what more transparent do
we have than law enforcement you see law
enforcement all over the place they do
so much for residents of the State of
New Hampshire so does all of the other
fishing game staff but law enforcement
are the ones that are more noticed out
there so it was determined that that is
where those funds would be and the way
that those funds work is we have always
been provided an appropriation of
Revenue within that accounting unit
7887 and the methodology is a transfer
is made on a quarterly basis based on
actual expenditures incurred so even
though there could be a lump sum
budgeted for that budget that fiscal
year budget we never actually received
100% of those revenues because it was
based on expenditures only and as you
can see by this chart fiscal years 26
and 27 have zeroed out because those
General funds were taken out in the
governor's budget the other question we
were asked was illustrate the impact of
the pay raises since fiscal year 2022 we
and benefit classes and it is important
to note that we have two divisions the
hatcheries and law enforcement that have
a very large appropriation for overtime
and holiday pay so it's not just class
10 full-time permanent positions it also
this pay raise affects overtime and
holiday pay and of course the associated
benefits with
that the next slide is 17 years of the
fishing game fund the balance from 2008
all the way to
2024 and as you can see we hit a low in
fiscal year 2015 of 1 and A5 million in
the fishing game fund and it was
certainly known prior to that about a
year or so prior to that because our
first infusion of General funds was
fiscal year
2014 that there was a significant
problem at the fishing game department
and we could no longer just rely on
unrestricted fishing game funds to
support ourselves with the expenses
exponentially the use of Fish and Game
funds by fiscal year I think is a nice
snapshot going all the way back to 2011
all the way to our current banial budget
submission of
2027 in the second column is our
unrestricted reeven revenue of course
all the way through fiscal year 24 is
actual unrestricted Revenue as well as
fishing game funded expenses actual
fishing game fund expenses 25 26 and 27
are budgeted only and those figures are
the governor's budget of course in the
variance column you can see the
significant difference in 25 26 and 27
of how that looks we're budgeting 14
million in Revenue yet we're expending
years without taking into account the
lapses that the governor has balanced
our budget on using the governor's
numbers without any infusion of General
funds for 26 or 27 would leave the
fishing game fund at a negative $2.5
million at the end of the bayum
which we know we're going to have lapses
that's not a question we just we have
always been told you cannot Budget on
lapses so we never have budgeted on
lapses it's an exercise on paper when
you do that it's not
realistic the other um information that
was asked for not at our last meeting
but UPF front by the LBA was about
personnel we have 193 authorized F
full-time employees one of them
unclassified we have five currently
unfunded in this banal budget and they
remain unfunded in the 26 and 27 budget
and I have a list of them right there
for you our current vacant positions we
have 18 of those all are critical to the
successful operation of the department
two have a start date of this fr Friday
one has an active off off offer should
be offer not office of employment I'm
sorry that's my typo two positions are
currently in the interview process
including one for my division four
division four positions are currently
being recruited six overall of these
positions are law enforcement and one is
a division Chief in the final slide is a
list of all of those positions with the
position number the division the title
and description of that position the
accounting unit where it is housed the
type of funding Federal other or fishing
game funds and the date since it's been
vacant so that and a nutshell is our
slideshow which thank you for the Kudos
that is good thank you very much it's
excellent welcome a question regarding
unrestricted funds so
what license fees
make up are unrestricted basically what
license fees well what what goes into
the unrestricted
funds well with the 13 parts of funds
most of of them appear to be
restricted no no it um on slide
number one two three four slide number
four what are our pots of unrestricted
revenues those okay so those
licensees go ahead I'm sorry uh license
is only about 35% of our total
unrestricted they make up only about 35%
of that total money okay and what's the
other
65% but it varies across all of these
these pots all of these pots like 9% is
for miscellaneous income um I think uh
ohrv and Marine unfunded Road Road Road
tolls are about 7 % it's about a million
and a half dollars per year between
those
two the Federal grant recoveries which
is the indirect charge on federal
grants that is 900 to a million dollar
per year that goes into the unrestricted
fishing game fund I think I asked the
question backwards so for instance
fishing licenses where does that come
in hunting licenses what pot is it in
are they unrestricted restricted well
they are they are
unrestricted with the exception of when
you buy as an example when you purchase
a resident no when you purchase a
resident fishing license for the year
your fishing license is
$44 in addition to that you pay a $1
Fisheries habitat fee that Fisheries
habitat fee is restricted it goes into
the Fisheries habitat account
$44 stays in the unrestricted Ed part of
Licensing and as a general if it can be
generalized if not be specific when was
the last time license Fe the the
unrestricted component of license fees
was increased 2018 2018 we had a
increase of $10 per type that was not
across the board license fee
increase it was $10 I believe on a
hunting and $10 on a fishing as well as
non-residents okay thank you you're
welcome any other questions as far as
we've gotten all right why don't we move
budget and you can which I guess starts
on page so now we're on just for the
people that are watching at home uh this
is Page 734 of the governor's uh
physical budget the PDF if you will
Mr chair it actually starts at the end
of
7:33 the fishing game oh you're right my
bad it I've got a big X on the top of
that page but yes it does start at the
very very bottom of page 733 thank
you so you just want to go forward from
there
and whatever you would like for me to do
I've never done it in this manner
usually it's a question answer type
thing but I get it um but if you could
uh
walk us through it certainly yeah
certainly do you want me to go through
each accounting unit or yeah okay okay
so the first accounting unit is called
non-game support and this is actually a
general funded accounting unit of
$100,000 and this is the match that goes
into the noname dedicated account per
RSA
22 colon 6 I believe it is so this is
basically in law that has in law that it
has to come out of General funds correct
for this yes correct and it is part of
our operating budget I actually have to
do a payment voucher for this and then
work with treasury to receive that
$100,000 back into our account is it for
General is it for your general use or is
it for a specific use on your side it is
specifically for noname right n noname
RSA great just a quick example of what's
non-game the non-game program it it
varies it could be carer blue
butterflies it could be um you know
salamanders a variety of species that
are not hunted species um typically it's
uh species that aren't hunted and then
it also includes our threatened and
endangered species as well but not all
Mame species are threatened and
endangered contrib send newsl
yes the non-game program relies heavily
upon
donations and we have to prove that we
have raised that amount in donations in
order to be able to apply for that
funds should I go on okay so the next
several accounting units are all within
the office of the director we have 7888
which is the expenses for our Fishing
Game Commission the 11 members we
reimburse them mileage and we pay for
their lunch for their monthly commission
meetings the next accounting unit is
1171 office of director this is where
the director and her staff up there in
the director's site moment represent
papovich sorry
if I may I know that the uh amounts are
really small but for the
commission there seems to be quite a big
drop for 25 and a back to even higher in
26 27 I know it's not a huge amount but
how come we saved so much money in 25 so
for fiscal year 24 I actually had to go
to fiscal committee to increase their
mileage budget they are entitled per our
SAA to receive mileage reimbursement for
the mileage that is incurred for them to
travel to fishing game business okay so
I had to go to fiscal committee and
increase that budget for 24 so 25's
budget of only
$112,000 is actually the budget that
passed and we are almost there for
spending so the director will make the
decision whether we go back to fiscal
and request more additional funds or if
we do something else so we upped it to
20,000 for instate travel reimbursement
for the upcoming banial budget so that
we did not fall
short you're
welcome so the next accounting unit is
Office of the director where we have our
class 10 Personnel that work directly
under the um director this is
HR
the Federal grant coordinator
legislation and Rule schools her
administrative assistant as well as her
salaries in class 11 and any other
Associated expenditures with the office
of the
director the next one down is our gifts
and donations account and at the last
meeting there was a couple of questions
about gifts and donations and how we
received
them we all set there one more question
that is one of our dedicated accounts I
know I just I just kind of missed the
window on the uh Office of the director
right we have an increase of about
100,000 if I recall correctly we were
talking was that an additional employee
that got reassigned there or is this an
increase in the expenditures on the same
number of employees we have the same
number of employees so it's increasing
expenditures on the same number of
employees yeah because it looks like an
almost 10% increase in the
cost that sounds like a lot of an
increase for a year over year so what
you see in fiscal year
24 is critical because it's actual
expenditures so we are dealing with a
whole we may have okay so I think uh
We've covered part of that uh the last
time but if you can really quickly go
again fiscal year 24 is actual
expenditures based on actual um cost
fiscal year year 25 is budgeted so quite
often when you submit a budget and you
have people in their pots of where where
they are right like we have people in
the office of director when you have
internal movement a person can move from
one position to another that isn't
reflected in a budget if you're in the
middle of a bium so that person could be
earning additional money we have to do
salary and benefit adjustments at the
end of the year to increase cost to be a
deficit did I totally confuse you now no
but you reminded me of what we talked
last time so I'm good for now thank you
you and are we good with gifts and
donations okay president
Murray looks like there was a
significant gift in um or acquisition in
2024 um and it's zero it out are there
Acquisitions you can just say
no not that would go in the gifts and
donations account that was a rather
unusual right opportunity that someone
who bordered uh property that we were
acquired acquiring wanted to make a
donation to the department as match for
those federal funds so that we could
purchase that land so the best place to
to put that in transparency was the
gifts and donations account it's
definitely a unique approach to trying
to you know acquire a land in a
different Manner and it was a way to
work this legally it's not something we
commonly do I'm not saying we wouldn't
do it again if if the opportunity arose
it landowner relations program
unfortunately this is one of the Class
10 permanent full-time positions that is
unfunded and remains
unfunded so right now we just have some
current expense and um some landowner
relations initiative cost in there which
cost
2162 is our transfers to oit as you can
see that is a very large amount
um 1.2 million and 1.3 million
27 our represent wer so last time we met
in the previous
budget we were told there was a problem
in out ofate
ohrv because we were harder to get
permission than the other states and
they were working on a computer system
so they could go online line has that
been finished finally well that has
absolutely nothing to do with transfers
to doit doit is not involved in that at
all they're not creating that system no
they are not doit does not do anything
like that for agencies so we have um
contracted with our online vendor that
currently sells our online
licenses and in law that has to be up
and ready and running by September of
this year and we are on track to do
that okay so what what's the other oit
money going out
for it's uh it's all of our uh network
connections it's computers for our staff
it's maintaining the software that we
have updates to uh our technology
systems and to be honest with you we
could use more I'll just up all of the
LIC that we have to buy it's all the
software licenses we have to pay for
and we receive an invoice from doit on a
monthly basis and we pay that invoice
based on their cost some of those costs
are direct cost for direct Personnel
that are embedded at fishing game as
well as direct cost of purchasing
computers and licenses for us and then a
good part of that invoice is for what is
called shared cost which all other state
agencies share in that cost
yeah it's a variety of things software
that papovich thank you um since you are
getting detailed invoices was there any
point in time where you guys look to see
if some of those Services if you are
allowed to look at other entities who
may provide them you may find better
deals than you have from we're not
allowed to do that okay so not even as a
hypothetical to help you decide nope
you all right that's doit 2114 is
actually Wildlife Legacy initiative this
is one of the 16 dedicated accounts and
this is a $10 donation that someone can
make at any time online or um in in our
front office and that $10 goes into this
account called The Wildlife Legacy
initiative and those funds are used to
pay for two accounting units up 2128 the
landowner relations program now in
statute the executive director can
determine where those funds can be
used and I believe the statute indicates
for an annual basis if I'm not mistaken
those funds have always as long as I've
been at fishing game been earmarked
towards the landowner relations program
so that accounting unit 2128 does not
cost the fishing game fund anything it
is um totally self-supporting by this
Wildlife Legacy initiative as you can
see there's only a class 29 that's used
as a transfer to pay 2128 accounting
incurred and then the final accounting
unit within the office of the director
8049 the wildlife Heritage
Foundation they are our nonprofit
partner that receives donations and they
um raise money on behalf of the
department and program staff or
Department staff can put in a Grant
application for
certain projects for certain um we have
had everything from Nets Predator Nets
at our hatcheries to a trailer for the
Wildlife division or it just it goes
across the board two ongoing projects
under the wildlife Heritage Foundation
are our canines are police
dogs as well as the berry Conservation
Camp
so that wraps up the first activity of
director and seeing no questions I'll
move on am I
okay um then we get into administrative
support which is my division the
business division the first accounting
unit actually is the public
specialty account and that is the
account that we use to purchase
merchandise and the revenues from the
sale of that merchandise go right back
account and then we
have accounting unit 2110 business
management which is me and several of my
staff we have some big ticket items in
this accounting unit I'd like to bring
your attention to the first first one of
which is indirect cost for
das H for about
$275,000 each year that is for overhead
cost in the Statewide cost allocation
plan to the Department of administrative
services for the work that they do on
behalf of non-general funded state
agencies we then have Debt Service which
is a line item within this accounting
unit to pay for past capital budget
Appropriations and treasury
automatically sweeps that class line for
debt
repayments then the next really big one
that you might notice is
retirement benefits health insurance for
our
retirees about a million dollars each
year very significant fish and game is a
self-funded agency is responsible for
paying the retirees health benefit cost
to are people who have retired represent
papovich thank you um I appreciate you
highlighting the line um it seems to
have grown from 775 to 1125 I
mean from 24 to 27 that is a steep steep
hill could you help us understand why is
it such a steep growth because this is
not
inflation I wish I could but I have no
control over over this dollar number um
we are provided figures by the
department of administrative Services
risk risk and
benefits section
that they estimate I assume based on the
current retirees that we have in the
cost of health insurance as it may be in
these future
years so those three numbers that I
provided to you the S cap
The Debt Service and the um
retirees uh health insurance those
figures are provided to us by other
state agencies we have no control over
what we plug in it's the same with
doit the doit I wish uh yeah it's it's a
different discussion agreed but look I
mean at the end of the day we have
control over what goes into Deb service
because you got to ask for those things
to be capitalized and then you know what
you're going to pay so you don't control
what this year but we want to make sure
that yes we have control up front but we
want to make sure we have enough to
cover that debt service again with the
indirect cost that you were bringing in
bringing up you know that's the DS and
whatnot um I understand that you have
less control over that I know that you
may not be able to change the amounts
that you owe for the benefits MH but I
would appreciate a bit more background
into again at least a breakdown
of why they're expect it to grow so
steeply is it a higher number of
retirees is it way more on health
insurance are the uh pension benefits
contributions that are required are
higher so I I hear you when you tell me
that you don't control what you owe on
this but understanding why you owe more
I think we would benefit from
understanding right whether again it's
higher number of retirees higher
pensions you know higher pension
contributions and we can get into a
whole sidebar on our uh you know funding
for the state pension plans and all that
that I I try to avoid desperately here
in the interest of time so just just in
terms of understanding what drives this
increases right even though you have to
maybe go ask the you know retirement
system or whatnot why in God's name are
you giving me this uh very highest
esates so I would have to ask and I I in
asking in the past it is a combination
of the age group at your agency and the
anticipated retirements we have a lot of
gray hairs at our agency oh no trust me
I've got I've done actual study actual
studies around that before and I
understand the mechanics of it but some
details on what drives this because look
what we need to understand is with an
Actuarial you'd get more than two two
years projection right so they'd be able
to tell us whether this will snowball
really hard or this is just a temporary
Spike or what is the trajectory that we
expect because again when we budget we
don't just look at the next budget cycle
and that's what I'm trying to get to
that even if we don't necessarily
control it we should be at least able to
see it a bit further down the road and
understand what's going on and what the
drivers are behind it we may not be able
to change what drives it but at least
get what's going on okay that's what I
would % agree with you sir thank you
very much for asking that question
because to be honest with you as I
walked in this door and I'm hearing 20
year 25 year 32 year and I'm seeing I'm
I'm realizing wow half of the staff is
going to be gone before I even get my
feet under me and it was actually one of
the questions I had immediately is like
I need to get an assessment of what we
look like going forward honestly I
haven't had the time to do it yet but it
is on my list as far as figuring out
what we need going forward thank
you when she first came on board I told
her my retirement date was March 1st of
26 so a year from now but wait to be
specific yeah I I'm trying to convince
them differently I I I have pushed that
out a little bit so but I'm one of those
gray hairs
so all right moving down
um unless there are further questions
for accounting unit
2110 all set accounting unit 2111
uh ohrv registration this is where the
cost for the registration program is
within the business division we have
increased that significantly for the
next
bium this account is funded fully by
ohrv revenues the online program that's
due to be um taking place this fall in
September is going to cost the
department a significant amount of money
much it's much more costly to run an
online program in this manner than it
will be
to leave it the way it is so hold on
just there so this is the the online
registration for snowmobiles and all is
now running well no it'll be in effect
September so that's why this budget has
and where is the increase the increas is
expenses thank you well that is
awesome you
like no I like the fact that it's going
to be online starting in September 1st
you said right in September where it's
in September do want to commit to
September 1st okay okay that's fair
thank
you anticipate a bigger
increase income as well right no we do
not we're going to lose income by
running this
program because it's going to cost the
department we have to for the ohrv
program we have to transfer 70 to 72% of
registration funds to dncr we keep the
remainder with that remainder we have to
run this ohrv registration program
within the business division we have to
run ohrv education and LA law
enforcement as well as ohrv enforcement
and law enforcement and we're going to
be retaining less funds because of
running the program not retaining from
the sale but running the program will
funds the
legislature why does it cost more to run
the program because it costs more to run
an online program than it does to run a
program
um well it wasn't our sell selling point
sir it was probably other PE no it was
not our selling point well so I will if
I may I I think that uh what we're going
to see is a transfer of people who
usually buy in person are going to then
buy online and from my understanding in
talking with everyone about this program
we're not anticipating a huge increase
in new
snowmobile purchasers but rather a
transition of the way that people are
acquiring their
license yeah so here's what we were told
in fiscal just so we're clear people are
not out of state people are not coming
to New Hampshire because they can't go
online and get their registration
they're instead going to Vermont and
Maine and now we're hearing that that's
not what we're going to expect sir I
would tell you again that argument did
not come from our department most
certainly did it came from your right at
the very top that's who comes to fiscal
so so at this point neither of us were
there I I hope that is I hope that is
correct I hope that what you were told
two years ago is correct because that
would be very optimistic for us um you
know all all I can say is We Know It The
Upfront cost is going to be costly for
us and managing it My Hope Is that we
can promote it we're going to work with
uh the tourism Bureau to help promote
this idea and hope that we can increase
the user groups so so a couple points
there you said The Upfront costs I
completely understand that are you
suggesting that that's why we're taking
a hit this year but the ongoing C the
operating costs will not be significant
are you suggesting the ongoing cost will
be significant as we may or may not
we're not sure yet we may or may not
have to hire a person for customer
service because people who purchase
things online typically have a lot of
trouble doing so we answer a lot of
customer service calls now with our
licensing program online the phones are
ringing constantly so once this program
is online we are
anticipating many many many calls all
day so which of your licensing programs
is already online that you're having
these problems to purchase a hunting or
fishing license
and you have more people to support that
program than to support not having that
program in other words to take the phone
to answer the phone to get the license
which I assume is the old way of doing
it or the other way of doing it no the
other way of doing it was a manual
form mail by mail basically no they went
into a license agent and purchased a
license on what was called a
multiform and then the and gave the form
to a
so what happened with the
form on a monthly basis they were sent
into the New Hampshire fishing game
department so they would didn't get
their license until the no they had a
license they got their license when they
purchased their license at an agent they
still do that sir they still do that
only it's an online platform now rather
than a piece of
paper yeah go ahead I think that the
slight disconnect here is that whether
you fill a paper form or where you go
online some people may need their
handheld I think what the department is
trying to say is that they didn't have
to do it because whoever was selling the
licenses was doing the handholding while
in this case the handholding would
become a Department's problem again
that's my understanding what you're
saying I haven't yet bought one so I
cannot claim any expertise whatsoever on
the topic I was looking classes up this
morning so soon or later I will be a
customer but just to you know clarify a
little okay so if we're not gaining
anything from out of state people as we
were led to believe we're going to and
it's been 2018 was the last time that we
raised our fees by $10 you're you're
combining two different things 2018 was
the last time we raise fees for licenses
we were talking ohrv
registrations okay so I'm a little
confused okay I guess I should have CL I
so given the difference between
so and ohrv assume includes snowmobiles
or the snow is a separate thing yes it
does that doesn't okay then when was the
last time you raised ohrv snowmobile
license fees oh they have gone up
recently actually there was just a two
or threee increase where they increased
a little
bit in each year um the agent fee went
from $3 to $4 to
five can I assume the agent fee will is
gone when you're doing online purchases
no it is not who who's the agent the
agent is our online vendor and that is
how they earn money for providing the
online platform for us to be able to
sell online so you're not using
our department Our IT department to no
absolutely not and why is that because
they could not do
it h H we told that Ken yeah that yeah
right I don't hearing all that I the it
was I heard about a years ago was
anticipated it would be doing it we
wondered why it took so long we told 18
months at
time never remember hearing about
dncr was that customary before we put it
online dncr gets a very large piece of
it's partially the trail maintenance
work they administer grants out to
snowmobile clubs for helping with the
trail yes right
yes so so for somebody like me was a
beginner can you break down the ohrv
fee can I break it down for you yeah you
said a bunch of goes to the to the agent
could just give me the actual breakdown
what goes how what is the total what's
the registration fee and how's it broken
down the registration fee we have at
least a dozen 15 different types
understand pick one okay pick a common
one I'm sorry but I cannot do that yeah
I don't have no detail I I I've seen a
few come in
um the the fee itself is like $34 we
um yeah I I will be happy to provide you
with more detail on that I don't have
depends upon the registration itself if
you belong to a club it's $30 less than
if you don't belong to a club your
antique is a different price than your
non- antique there's all these nuances
States
inre we heard two years ago well we're
certainly going to try well well hang on
so but this this could be good news so
basically you're saying no outut ofers
are coming to buy these things so it
would really not hurt we did not say
that well no I do want to clarify it I'm
not saying that we don't have out ofate
snowmobilers coming okay what we were
saying is we're not anticipating an
increase in that so I just want to be
clear on that we do have out ofate folks
coming to New Hampshire to enjoy what we
have to offer here um but we're not
anticipating a huge influx that's going
to all of a sudden generate this great
Revenue that's you know going to offset
all this I'm hoping that that is the
case that would be wonderful to bring
more people here and okay
Andover
cost thank you uh can I just clarify
because all of a sudden it seems a
little bit clouded the difference
between registration and license uh when
they're registering their
snowmobile um someone from New York
coming here they get a registration they
have to register their snowmobile in New
Hampshire or can they use their
registered snowmobile from New York and
if they come over here is there a
license or a fee that they have to pay
in order to use their snowmobile in New
Hampshire that is a I'm a little
confused about registration versus
license a license is for hunting and
fishing a registration is for ohrv and
ATV
vehicles so it it acts as a license it
acts as a license so it's not they're
not registering their vehicle here
they're registering it in New York but
the registration is their usage fee here
so yes
exactly you're welcome okay so I'm going
to ask the question a different
way it sounds like a fishing game gets
just just numbers You' ble left so far
less than 50% of
the registration fee across the board
and and I don't care about exact numbers
but my point is this why don't we just
double and triple
the the portion of that that goes to F
fishing game to get a new Total so if it
was $34 and you got 10 now it would be
you know 4 4 or $54 of which You' get 20
or
30 again that that would have to be done
through legislation oh I understand how
it has to be done I'm asking you what
the impact would be so the impact of
that is would not have any effect at all
on where our problem is our problem is
with the unrestricted fishing game fund
the ohrv program is dedicated it is part
of a the 16 dedicated accounts that we
have in the department and those funds
can only be used for ohrv activities
it's a like a game we're playing here
okay fair fair enough I'm learning as we
go this is great so I guess I should
have asked about the fishing license and
hunting license are those unrest what
goes into the unrestricted
funds give me I mean just give me a big
one not all of them fishing licenses 4 $
4 from a resident fishing license goes
into the unrestricted fund okay now that
$44 of how much is the whole license fee
47 oh so in that case you get more than
the ohrv case absolutely but the fishing
but the fishing license is also
purchased online can be yes it is so why
is it so costly to get an ohrv
registration online versus getting a
fishing license online our fishing and
hunting license online platform was
developed many years ago and we paid for
it back then already paid it's already
bought and paid for hang on but you're
now you're you're back to that whole
upfront fee I get that whole thing but
then I asked you if the ongoing cost was
then lower and you said no not to
administer it here in the department no
it is not going to be lower where is the
administered it's in the department so
you see what I'm leading up to here yeah
I think we're going I think we're
getting very off track no we're not at
all I think we're running into a serious
problem with the way things are being
run well so to back up so I think the
the key is we have many dedicated funds
that and we have some unrestricted right
the unrestricted is where we have the
the issue right the concern that I have
or the thoughts that I have had about
these funds is I'm wondering if there
isn't an Avenue to to look at these
restricted funds differently can we is
there a way to say maybe there's a cap
on the amount of money and at a certain
point in each restricted fund there's an
ability to draw down an X percentage or
the the remainder to the unrestricted
fund that's one Avenue to think about
okay hang on and and I totally agree
with that in fact I'm I've already
thought that I'm just unrestrict these
things which okay so I'm on board with
that don't get me wrong yeah but but but
but even separate from that the question
I'm trying to understand whether they're
restricted or unrestricted it sounds
like what you're telling me is that in
the case of fishing licenses for example
you do them online and you capture most
of that funding to whether it's an
unrestricted or restricted fund fishing
game captures most of that funding
whereas in the case of the ohrv even
though it may be going into into a
restricted place you capture less than a
third of that funding and yet they're
both basically online platforms ident
they should be identical in terms of
their operations I understand there
could be an upfront cost although don't
first of all I don't understand why the
fishing game well excuse me while the
fishing and hunting license part is
managed by fish and game if I understand
that correctly no it's managed by our
online vendor as well same vendor
different yes same vendor we're going
through the same vendor it's going to
run on the same type of platform okay
that's good news so can we expect then
that in the future they would not be
getting such a high percentage of the
total fee so our online vendor sir is
not getting a percentage of the
fee the the majority of
ohrv registration funds is transferred
to
dncr which is what department of
resources and natural development it
used to be DN Department natural
cultural
resources for their grant and aid
program as well as for them to run a
Trails
bureau
if so just to summarize I understand
this correctly there is a significant
difference in the way we uh the
legislature Define the use of the
revenues that you are getting in the
sense that you know the hunting fishing
you get to get most of it while for the
ohvs they designate that a big chunk of
what you guys get moves into this other
you know entity who then starts
dispensing various grants to maintain
trails and whatnot right correct what I
would appreciate understanding
is what what is the fee structure
through the same vendor for a hunting
fishing license versus a
ohrv cuz if I recall correctly they get
what $123 per hunting fishing license
and I think you said about 5 for an ohrv
can you help me I will please currently
in law they you are exactly right it is
$1 per license type is retained by the
agent so for our licensing platform our
online vendor is an agent and they
retain $1 per license type
sold they also retain a $2 transaction
fee that is what funds them other than
upfront cost of when the program was
developed we do not have any ongoing
cost with our online vendor that is how
they earn their money for the ohrv
registration
program in
statute the agent fee is
$5 per
registration so if you register a sled
to go up north you pay that agent at the
store or at fishing game $5 can you
explain why there's a difference there
that is how the law is written there's
lobbyists who come in and they it's it's
statut it didn't come from fishing game
it's
statutory okay so what impact would it
have if we change that to a
buck or or to the same it's the same
person it's the same organization
correct well well if you'd let me finish
with um representative Papi's
question when we bring this online in
September part of our contract is to
retain at the department $4 of that
transaction fee so that our online
vendor is going to continue with the
just the $1 fee just like they have now
with licens is and that's going to allow
us to help offset the cost of running
the program
internally so we've actually become more
efficient we found a way to earn some
money so if I may the so basically that
means that once we get out of the
one-time costs yes if you guys can get
by without hiring a new person to
support this this may benefit the
department over all because you would
now get in the past you got your $5 when
somebody registered directly with you
guys but that didn't happen a lot
correct most people just go wherever in
the field they are correct now most all
online transactions you get to keep four
out
of5 which hopefully you know would be a
net benefit compared with how it was in
the past and that's assuming the same
level of registration is nothing
changing even though I will agree that I
have also been told while I was not on
fiscal but I remember being told that
yeah this is going to be a boosting out
of state registrations and all that be
that as it may whatever was said was
said you guys were not necessarily
saying that it is understood so even at
a flat no change in the registrations
this should still once we go past the
initial stuff initial you know upfront
expenses they should benefit the
Department financially even if we don't
get new
registrations unless you guys have to
hire more people to help out you know
going above and beyond what you're
getting I'm just trying to understand
financially you know whether this is a
good program to continue or not because
frankly if you're telling me just it's
just money down the drain it's not that
hard to cut it so for the upcoming banal
budget we increased class 20
specifically to cover Postage and
shipping
of the decals that we're going to have
to send out to the people who purchase
online right y people who are driving up
Route 93 on a Friday from out of state
and they go and purchase a registration
online they're still going to have to
wait for that
decal so we have to do the Fulfillment
at the agency it's very different than a
paper hunting or fishing license that
you go online you buy your license you
print off a piece of paper that's your
license I hear you but if I may I just
want to make sure since I've never had
an ATV and or an A or you know or a
snowmobile and nor am I planning to get
one at my age um you are saying that if
I drive in with a snowmobile and I want
to use it in New Hampshire now I got to
wait for the decal you cannot get the
decal when you pay at an agent how you
can if you pay an agent absolutely at an
agent I'm not talking online online is
online supposedly you new three weeks
ahead of time you're going to go to New
Hampshire you do it you wait for the
mail it comes in but if I would go to an
agent I can pick up my decal on the
sport cuz they have deals there
absolutely that makes much more sense
than what I thought I was hearing thank
you for uh confirming I'm good well it
doesn't make sense to me you could no
reason you couldn't print out a
license you can print out a license
can't print out a decal with it's a
sticker it attaches to the it attaches
to the machine yeah it attaches to the
unit and to say it will cause additional
law enforcement concerns to say because
everybody can easily say oh well I had
it on there but I must have lost it in
the field or it's in the mail you know
y yeah is it possible that if they have
their receipt they could go to an agent
once they get here and just get their
sticker is that possible at this point
it is not that is one Avenue that we are
considering might help huh right
inventory is sent up out specifically to
each agent and the inventory of course
has to be accounted for so agents have a
predetermined inventory that they are
responsible
for yeah go ahead representative thank
you was there a
misunderstanding um around this program
with did you expect the large chunk of
money was going to go to resources as
opposed to staying in fishing game and I
realized I guess resources uses it for
for its programs but was there a little
disconnect between where the larger
chunk of money was going to go no it's
always been this way as long as I've
been with fish and G transfers have gone
over to dncr of around 70 to 72% of
Revenue even though you're doing pretty
much even though we do the registration
program
yes what our say is
that we can look in our oh okay you
don't have to look it up right now just
get it to me after the fact is fine well
it's it's listed in our dedicated
accounts the
RSA ohrv is RSA
23 just a fair warning to the committee
that's one of the hardest rsas to read
and follow when when you get to it but
it's easy to repeal it it could be easy
to repeal yes but you'll see it's a very
complex uh funding stream that comes in
and how it's directed and like the
department was saying there's many
different types of registrations and
when you get to that RSA and then
there's a snowmobile one too um it's
quite
complex but uh so I I would like to get
from you not right now but for all of
these different bees licenses whatever
are the synonyms you have for those
kinds of things um what the what the
fees are and what the breakdown is of f
to the agent funding to whatever funding
to fishing game because I speciically
for ohrv no no no no for everything all
for all components oh okay that's I know
that's a that's a partial list probably
but no that's unrestricted yeah re I
want restricted as
well I want to know so I understand that
you are you what you've been telling us
is
that you're short funds and am I'm not
hearing that correctly
we are short unrestricted fishing game
funds yes we are okay so I would like to
try to help to alleviate that problem
but not doing it through General funds
I'd rather doing do it through usage
fees which seems to be the way to go in
my opinion agree uh and without an
understanding which clearly I do not
have I'll admit it and you can laugh at
me it's fine I'm I'm on board with that
um but without that as a place to begin
it's going to be difficult to figure out
how to how to work through it but that's
I'd like to get input from you all and
the best way to increase fees to
increase your uh unrestricted funds to
fund fishing game yes sir R and just on
right I mean I've been here last year
and I cannot claim I can I can say that
I have a general understanding but if
you'd uh start quizzing me on the
various fees and various breakdowns I
would be lost within 15 seconds so I
think when you do a budget like this and
it's such a complicated environment that
you guys work in well if we don't
understand how it works how in God's
name are we going to fix it correctly so
I know it's going to be quite a bit of
work to get that breakdown on you know
think of it this way think about the
life of a dollar as it comes in and goes
out of you know
this every dollar that comes in on a
hunting license so so much of it goes to
the agent fees so much goes to the
unrestricted fine look at the revenues
right never mind the expenditures but
then we get into registrations totally
different thing and again you had a
bunch of different Revenue sources all
of which go into unrestricted presumably
all of those may have similar stories
right where you know so much of the uh
license we talked about the agents agent
fees are clear right that's the one that
you actually get the whole thing and
there is no need for a
story you know court fines and penalties
okay I guess there is not a lot of story
but basically we need to understand what
comes in what are the different cuts
that go where what is currently
restricted that maybe doesn't need to be
restricted so there may be parts of what
you do that are currently restricted
because the legislature in the wisdom
decreed so but the agency feels that
maybe there is a reasonable case to be
made that revenue or at least part of
Revenue does not need to be restricted
and you know if you guys keep saying
that we have we are fine on the
restricted Revenue but we really have a
shortage on the unrestricted at least
part of the solution has to be examined
as which of your restricted revenues
doesn't need to be restricted or it
generates revenues in excess of what you
need to spend so some of it could be
unrestricted I know I'm I'm good I no I
yeah thank you I fully agree with you so
if I may sir um so let's back up a
little bit first off the licenses the
licenses are covered under rule and we
have the authority to change those
license fees they were changed just you
know in 2018 we did raise them you see
how we compare across the states um
there are little areas where I think we
can still probably increase like charge
for duplicate license things like that
smaller incremental changes that won't
make significant difference but every
little bit counts um as far as the the
the place that I see our biggest hold up
is in the restricted funds we have money
there it's restricted in the use and we
those are the areas where we can
actually increase fees we have a since
19 I think it's 98 the habitat fee has
been
$2.50 since 19 something similar 1998 or
something our fee related to Fisheries
has
has1 so we have the opportunities to
raise those fees but my concern is if we
raise them and we can't use them what do
we do then right and that's where I
don't know the mechanism but if we could
get some help with that that would be
suitable for us I know the mechanism
okay you know I mean that that's the
reality of it yes we have some fees
licenses that we can you know change and
Tinker with but it's not a significant
amount it's these other restricted funds
that we could actually generate I mean
we I have a list here that I'd be
willing to share with you I asked Kathy
to pull this really quickly but our
wildlife habitat fee alone $1
142,5
67 if we just doubled that by doubling
the fee and if you look at inflation
that's exactly where we should be on
both of these the fisheries and the
habitat um the wildlife habitat fee so I
don't disagree with you I love that you
guys are thinking this way and I'm just
honestly I'm new here I'm trying to
figure out how do we make this happen
and how can we address this back to your
point chairman about the ohrv you know
given the fact that we do not have
General funds necessarily allocated in
the current uh proposed budget by the
governor um if we were to do anything
with
ohrv those funds would help us ensure
that we could probably hire an
additional conservation office offer
what I'm concerned about right now
without having those General funds is we
may not be able to hire the five
vacancies that we have now granted those
those officers would have to be
contributed you know to their time to
that event and to that specific thing
but nonetheless that could help us if we
were to raise those those fees and they
only have to be applied to that specific
thing we left the law as it is again
right we can change that so I would
you're new I'm new let's get together
that sounds good because what you're
suggesting sounds fantastic if you could
give us those kinds of recommendations
um that's exactly what I'm looking for
okay I'm sorry if I'm very Inc
convoluted about the way I get to that
point but no it's okay and I was trying
to jump in a little bit earlier but I I
just I didn't want to be interruptive to
people's conversations papich and just
as a quick Point um when there is a fee
that's for a service
right I was saying this earlier today in
addition different meeting it's kind of
bad policy to you know not increase it
for 10 years and then have to take a 50%
inflation adjustment cuz everybody's
going to remember the one time when you
increased it to catch up not the nine
years when they got a lesser fee because
inflation happened so I would suggest
that we not only adjust what needs to be
adjusting appropriately look at how much
of it needs to be restricted and how
much it doesn't but then also look at
putting into stat whether it's through
hb2 or through a separate bill to be
passed later you know some inflation
related fee increases so that there is
very clear expectations that hey if
there is 3% inflation this feing is
going to increase by 3% again it's not
your department you cannot do that on
road tolls because everybody would hate
to have to find three cents to pay a
toll but on fees like this that are paid
on a
transaction it's it it just seems better
policy and yet we we don't do it and you
know maybe we should consider it again
not everywhere but in the right places
so thank you chairman
wer so we're running a little long on
this but I want to come back to a
project that took me 10 years to get a
hike safe car with a lot of opposition
from the
department now it brings in a lot of
money so where do I find that in this
budget under accounting unit
762 so I have budgeted approximately
$300,000 per
year in hike safe revenue for the search
account where do I see hike safe it's
under estimated source of funds for
search and rescue under 06 agency
income on page 762 towards the bottom of
the
page so on 2025 it
only we that the income was only
191,000 well that's what's budgeted this
fiscal year however the actual for 24 as
you can see was just under 364,000
right well we do a budget way ahead of
time so it's it's a budget so it's the
whole previous year was actuals were
were way higher than budgeted so now the
remaining budget is lower they'll
actually have a significant Surplus in
25 they just don't report it yet it's
what I was struggling with earlier this
morning but years before that we had to
put 100,000 extra into search and rescue
because it came up short so now it
should be almost overfunded so you're
finding other ways to use that extra
money we're we're not using it for
anything other than search and rescue
activities search and rescue is one of
our dedicated accounts well when I saw
the latest a lot of it went in for
public discussions and and dive training
and other things that went somewhere
else
once so the funds are dedicated to
search and rescue which involves
training our officers and our responders
to be able to do this specialized work
um to say it's overfunded sir no I think
we're actually right where we need to be
I know there have been some proposals
for perhaps increasing search and rescue
funding I don't think we necessarily
need that I kudos to you thank you for
the hike saf glad to have some some
exess and I want you to understand that
once in a while we're not stupid we can
figure out we can figure out where money
needs to come from I love that and I
don't understand why I had all the
opposition from the agency I don't
either sir I iame I hope that you won't
have that experience with me because if
anything you'll find out I'm Pie in the
Sky I'm I'm always thinking about new
and creative way so I'm I'm willing to
work with you all but it should Tak me
10 years to get that pass 100% the
opposition from the agency it wouldn't
have taken so
long anyway just a point I want to make
we're here to help you we're trying to
make everything work we're looking at
the big picture and sometimes we run
into things that don't make sense to us
and then when we try to make a
suggestion I don't like the fact we've
never done that don't bother us you
don't know anything oh I hope that
you're not receiving or feeling that way
today because I'm very open to your
ideas and certainly want to hear I mean
just want to make a point the more ideas
at the table the better way we can get
trying to work together absolutely
appreciate that thank you hike safe card
is very successful f for our department
so thank
you represent Dy so going back to these
machines and and the groomers are
getting $4 of your fee the the license
fee registration fee excuse me the
registration fee the groomers well the
the field the people who actually groom
the Feld Trails excuse me no oh no where
does that $4 go no that's not the I
thought that was $4 $5 agent fee stays
with the agent who sold registration
okay what what's happening is um I think
it's I don't remember the percentage but
a chunk of it does go to dancer for the
trails maintenance work oh okay I
thought you said $4 went to the trail no
the $4 is actually for the the vendor
who sending selling the okay all right
that cleared that up thank you you're
all right would you like us to so where
would you like me to continue we stopped
registrations we did licensing correct
2118 okay we can we can so I guess the
licenses I'm I'm
sorry okay so then we have Fleet which
is the last accounting unit within the
business business division Fleet is a
central accounting unit to cover all of
our Fleet expenditures that are not part
of like a hunter education or aquatic
education program which are 100%
federally
funded I think you'll see that class 20
we stayed pretty much with uh current
expense class 70 is used exclusively to
pay fuel cost cost mostly to do for the
do
743 and that wraps up the business
division then we go on to our public
affairs division which is promotions
marketing education all of our
department-wide
media Au 2120 is the main account in
public affairs houses most of the people
in the account the class line 069 our
promotional marketing you'll see a
significant increase there it is our
desire to engage in more Market in and
department the next one down is aquatic
resources education which the M tell
745 sorry aquatic Ed and the one
underneath at Hunter Ed 2121 are both
very similar these are education
programs that are primarily funded with
federal funds Hunter education is on
y moving to down on
7:47 we have Wildlife Conservation
education this um just pays for one
full-time employee who is dedicated to
conser Wildlife Conservation especially
in our schools and with students budget
shows two I'm sorry budget shows two one
of them is unfunded oh one's unfunded
okay one is unfunded yes there are two
unfunded moving on to 748 the wildlife
program the first accounting unit is
2125 which is non-game species
management which we have touched upon a
little bit this is one of our dedicated
accounts the wildlife division has the
most dedicated accounts within the
department as far as
divisions meaning that there are no
accounts the next one down which starts
at the bottom of 749 but is mostly on
750 is the wildlife program management
which houses most people outside of the
non-game program within the wildlife
Division and this does have a small
amount of fishing game funds within it
but a large component of this accounting
will keep going okay so down on 751 we
have pheasant and there's only one class
line in our pheasant account and that is
to purchase pheasants in the RSA clearly
states that funds received from the sale
of these permits and funds within this
account can only be used for the
yes that's
it's fund it's aant F it's the Pheasant
fund
yes it's on my list of 16 dedicated
accounts under Au 2153 and you would see
the RSA
there halfway down on the same page 751
we have the game management account
which also is a dedicated account there
are no full-time people in here we do
have a small amount of over time which
is utilized to man moose and deer check
fall so moving
on about twoth thirds down page 752 is
the wildlife damage AB abatement it's a
very small account and it's
only one of two accounts within this
entire division
that has a portion of fishing game funds
in it we have one full-time person and
this person sits at USDA for the most
part and they are involved in the bare
mitigation and bare complaints human
Wildlife conflict issues human Wildlife
you say it's so much better than me I
used to run that
program that's why she's the director
on page 753 we have the wildlife habitat
conservation and we were talking about
the $2.50 wildlife habitat fee that has
been the same since
1998 that in conjunction with federal
funds fund this program there is one
full-time person who works as a wildlife
habitat conservation biologist within
this
account as you can see for fiscal year
24 actual expense almost $3 million in
land Acquisitions and
easements that was for land purchases
and we don't budget too heavily within
that account because we don't have a
crystal ball we don't we don't know
what's coming down the line what is
going to be available to us to be able
to purchase and typically when that
opportunity comes along there are
federal funds that come along with it
and we would do an accept an expend
through fiscal to increase that class
line
and what was that
fund wildlife habitat conservation page
753 no I've got that but that's also the
name of the fund yes it
is just so everyone is aware the table
that the department put also has a
column for accounting unit so it's a
good crosswalk to go from the budget to
the dedicated fund to the RSA I don't
have a problem with the accounting units
I've got those what I'm trying to
associate with the dedicated fund names
that is the name yeah no I got that but
that's but that's not in the budget
division seeing no questions we'll go on
to page 755 which starts the Inland
management nothing extraordinary to talk
about there I don't
think sure um is the the um large amount
of benefits on line 60 is that the same
issue as what you had before for the
general um
agency you know you've got your staff
Personnel 78,000 and your benefits 400
is it the same cons the same situation
absolutely thank you
okay as you know class 10 positions are
budgeted on that position as well as
their benefit package at the time that
the budget is
created and if you look at 24 we used a
lot less than what it looks like we had
a couple of vacancies
truthfully at the bottom of page 755 We
Begin
hatcheries hatcheries
for infrastructure is critically
years current
expenses we didn't even budget as much
as we spent in fiscal year 24 we did go
up a little bit on heat electricity and
water and we did increase our
contractual maintenance a little bit to
help alleviate some of those
infrastructure
issues you said underfunded is that did
I hear that corre it is underfunded so
too few people because it's mostly
people right no there's there's too
little money to handle the critical
infrastructure needs of the Hatchery
system so where is
that where's that where's that dollar
amount represented in the budget the
dollar amount that we have in here now
is under class 48 contractual
maintenance buildings and grounds which
we did increase by 150 ,000 in each
year okay fair enough um so you you had
10 people right roughly is that no we
have 30 people in 30 people so right
right 30 people so a lot of people a lot
of money
um and yet you say it's underfunded
because you need more money for the
maintenance the infrastructure is
underfunded yes so what are the people
the people must be doing something then
other than just that obviously oh yeah
they're running our hatcheries they're
taking care of the fish they okay so
it's a maintenance that's underfunded by
how much the maintenance of the
buildings how how
underfunded that well yeah I mean in the
capital budget alone we have like $6
Million worth of infrastructure that's
needed um from the previous that's what
we're working on right now from the
previous B and so now um this new
capital budget there's not much listed
in there because we have projects that
are ongoing right now but the next go
around I anticipate we're going to see
another several million large probably a
large ask another five or six million so
you did get six million in the current
we where we are now for yes Cent yes
yeah okay and that's what we're working
through right now representative ended
up to be four and a half but we had a
six and a half ask we ended up with four
and a half okay chairman wer how many
fish are we producing a
year I don't have the answer for that
That I Used to Know It wait a minute I
knew it for a moment we don't count fish
we count pounds it was pounds yeah I
trying to remember I don't have it with
me but it often seems to me as I look at
all the capital budget on this and all
the repairs and all the complaints that
this is not economical I mean this
should be paid for by the fishing
licenses right I don't think we bring in
license we don't raise deer and yet
people go out and pay for a hunting
license to shoot deer I'm sure that that
if we didn't raise fish that still be
fish well it's a different species of
fish and what we're working on obviously
is on the fish Inland Fisheries habitat
feed is working on improving the habitat
so that they're sustaining the fish that
we're actually raising right so that
then we can maybe decline on our
production and allow for natural native
fish and with that being said if we used
all of our fishing license revenue on
fish we wouldn't have a law enforcement
division we wouldn't have a business
division that's because business and law
enforcement don't create licenses no and
I'm thinking that if we didn't have all
these fish hatcheries we'd still sell
fishing
licenses not if there's no fish to catch
what are we paying for fish per fish per
fish or per pound yeah I I'll have to
get that for you sir I'm sorry sorry I
don't have that number
just often thought as as I look at all
the capital budget on all this and all
the complaints and all the repairs and
all the all the money that goes into
these fish hatcheries through the years
that well to put it in perspective sir
our fish hatcheries are very very
old a couple of them are like a hundred
years old our newest one is 50 55 years
old and we deferred Main M on these
facilities for years because of budget
constraints about 30 years ago I called
up to get to buy fish to put in a
pond it cost me
$200 for 100
fish
and it was from a private
contractor not from fishing
game most of them died anyway but we
that worked for the Hatchery okay but he
sold them to me privately which made me
suspicious would make me suspicious too
thank you the the fact of the matter is
is that we are in a state where um much
of our facilities have been neglected
when you know the two things that always
got sort of pushed aside were Outreach
and education and uh
facilities maintenance of facilities
Whenever there was a budget cut those
are the two areas that got cut the the
most and so now we're trying to make up
for that deficit with this new um
Innovative Hatchery coming online that's
going to create a different avenue for
us a different perspective for us and
we'll start hopefully to transition all
the other hatcheries to more current
methods and you may find that we aren't
going to have as many hatcheries we may
be able to produce as many fish in fewer
hatcheries with a less overhead in the
long term I hope so
too that the Hatchery the Innovative
Hatchery yeah it right now our
hatcheries are flowthrough systems the
water yes yes so you're familiar it goes
right through the new Hatchery is going
to allow us to recycle water it's going
to allow us to manage the contaminant
levels it's going to be very
state-of-the-art Innovative um it's
actually probably going to be the
pilot project for the United States to
is well it's a public resource
sir but certainly we will be I'm sure
giving tours about the the new Hatchery
once it's
online it's New Hampton Newton we just
started construction they have just
taken down the runways from the former
Hatchery we're in the process of uh the
construction right now anticipated
October of 26 that we should be opening
the doors and yeah it's very
exciting but to your point I think we we
will get there you might have to just
years okay ala sorry so our next account
on page
757 is the Fisheries habitat management
which is a dedicated account funded with
that $1 Fisheries habitat fee and
federal funds we have two full-time
people who work under this account that
are dedicated to Fisheries
habitat the next account down way at the
bottom of page 757 broodstock Atlantic
salmon has gone
away because we stopped selling that
salmon permit many years
ago so as you can see it has been zeroed
out we in ra years ago yep but this goes
to your point sir like was this cost
effective and it wasn't and so that's
why we no longer do this correct and we
permit sale of fish
food does anyone know it's a quiz anyone
know where the revenue comes from to
[Laughter]
it comes from the vending machines at
our hatcheries that you put a quarter in
and you can get a handful of pellets to
feed the fish so this account has been
around for many many many years and it's
a dedicated account and in statute the
funds can only be used for purchasing
equipment at our
with all due respect for whoever the
legislators were at the time a dedicated
fund for a few thousand a year seems to
be a u desperate candidate for a cutting
floor so
um I honest to God it's 5,000 a year
just the overhead of keeping track of
the darn thing is probably bigger than
on the top of page 759 is Fish
Conservation this was a new uh
accounting unit that was implemented
with this current banial budget that
we're in as you can see in fiscal year
expenditures it was kind of developed
to take the place of the salmon account
but it's to be
self-funded so until we get some Revenue
in there we're not going to incur any
expenditures what's it
for if you had
Revenue we were the we were anticipating
hiring a part-time person at in under
class
50 to work in the Inland Fisheries
division on Fish Conservation
I can't speak any more to it than that
it would just it would further help us
with like uh fish habitat improvements
and things like that but it was designed
to
be um with donations so there were no
expenditures in 24 because we didn't get
any donations
in so that wraps up the Inland Fisheries
division so on the top of page 760 We
Begin law enforcement and the first
accounting unit is ohrv education
training and
enforcement we have seven full-time
staff within this accounting unit and as
you look at class 049 transfers to other
agencies that's 6.5 million those are
the funds that are transferred to
dncr based on registration sold that's
our next account in law enforcement on
761 is the Deputy Co program which they
have moved away from having a deputy Co
program although the colonel did want to
continue funding it in the next
bium I apologize just a quick question
on the previous $6.5 million I
understand why okay is there any way um
you could provide thoughts on what uh
notwithstanding existing legislation do
they really need 6.5 million to do what
they are doing I cannot speak to another
agency's cost sir a I can't sorry fully
understood I appreciate it it's it's not
okay so then going down to 1186
self-funded and right now um we don't
funds then we go to representative
wier's favorite account on page 762
rescue there are no full-time staff in
search and rescue obviously it's
pay then all the way down at the bottom
of 763 we have conservation law
enforcement which is where the general
funds have historically been since
Mr
chair yeah represent P Phillips my
apologies to everyone here I have an
appointment I have to run to so I'll be
watching the video of the rest of this
from home tonight thank you than
okay continue so if there are no
questions on law enforcement that
completes the law enforcement division
and brings us to marine fisheries
management nothing extraordinary no
major changes in marine fisheries
765 we can turn to page
766 and at the bottom of such is the
reserve program affectionately known as
gibner the Great Bay National estuary in
research
either people come to that want to have
their own little Oyster Bed on there
outside the Waterfront lot in Great Bay
no no that's not that's not us okay this
is separate thought I thought you
licensed
them we licensed them out of Region
Three the Region Three office yes but
yes we but it's not in the reserve if I
may ask what is it because I don't know
what it is the program the gibner you
said gibner it's it's an estrian it's
like a you know what a wild life uh
Reserve is yes a refuge this a similar
approach um they do a lot of Outreach
and education there they've do a lot of
research there and actually we're in the
process of getting it um worldwide recog
ized because of its abilities and its
uniqueness to the salt marsh
area you're welcome it is primarily
federally funded about 70% and those are
Noah
grants next we have salt marsh
monitoring and restoration program at
the bottom of page 767 it's a relatively
new program
as a matter of fact we did not even have
a budget for 25 because we brought the
funds in in fiscal year 24 through a
either a GNC or perhaps a GNC fiscal it
I think it was just GNC I don't think it
met the threshold for fiscal committee
and then represent muray thank you um
yeah I noticed the 2025 all the zeros
and I'm wondering is this an an ongoing
kind of a program or um since there was
that Gap is this related to particular
storm damage um that would be sort of a
one-time restoration as opposed to
ongoing projects it's ongoing projects
it is not related to storm damage thank
welcome and as you can see it is
federally funded no fish and game funds
funds next on The Hit List here on page
768 is the coastal cleanup fund which is
also a brand new
fund and these funds are actually
derived from a $15 fee on derelict
fishing
gear you may remember that going through
the
legislature derel fishing gear yes how
well it yeah it depends on the type of
gear some of the gear has to be labeled
Fisher on the top of page 769 we have
the gibner Pack 2020 which is also
affectionately known as The Glen Cove
project I don't know if any of you have
had an opportunity to go out there and
view this project we
inherited if you will a very large
parcel of land out on Great
Bay and received several at least three
very large federal grants to totally
redo and renovate this
property yes and we have removed some
we're renovating some it's a very large
beautiful
project so as you can see there are no
fun funds in fiscal year 27 because it
is scheduled to be
completed and that completes the marine
fisheries
division we have one division left and
that is facilities and lands there are
only two accounting units the first of
which is 2117 on the top of page
770 this is the public boat access
no large increases
here with the exception of I guess a
little bit in our consultant line and
engineer and that is 100% funded with um
dedicated funds which is the $5 boat
registration fee that comes to us
directly from the Department of Safety
and federal funds and then the last
account unit is on page 771 what we call
facility maintenance we have six
full-time staff here they do various
construction and maintenance of our
facilities on not only on Hazen drive
but they also go around to our Regional
Offices and
hatcheries we also pay the majority of
our class 23 heat electricity and water
for our not only our headquarters but
um and I don't think there's
anything odd there this is mostly
fishing game funded very little federal
funds and the only other two accounts
are unemployment
compensation which we've budgeted at a
whopping $50 in our workers compensation
we have to pay directly for workers comp
because we are a self-funded agency so
we base we are
incurred and that brings us to the end
of our
budget represent Murray yeah two
questions I missed something back on 765
um the general fund was zeroed out where
is that where that money hold on
yep it's it's part of
765 under law enforcement so that's law
enforcement those are the general funds
that were taken from our bu budget
during the governor's phase and so this
she zeroed those out she zeroed those
out so this is a big and the incre and
all Appropriations remain the same yeah
so as you can see fishing game funds
went from 3.9 actual to four and a half
in fiscal year 25 to 6.2 and
6.3 it's under law enforcement it's so
that was one of the what account number
and the other sorry the other question
um or is there anything else to say
about the governor's cut other than you
probably need the money back so it will
it will impact us for certain
significant what would be the impact
since we're here well we so for the
longest time we weren't getting General
funds we finally started getting General
funds we have uh five vacancies
currently for law enforcement if we
aren't able to get this funding we will
not be able to those positions which are
desperately needed um the other piece is
as I mentioned before we have 38 field
officers and four uh serving an
administrative um with 38 across the
state our officers are often working
many many days straight and when you
have all the rescues and the events that
occur on the weekends you know they're
coming off a mountain one day and then
the next day they're called in because
of uh something else has happened over
time it increases our po
it increases our potential for overtime
it increases our potential for workman's
comp because people get injured when
they don't have time to rest things like
that it's it's a domino effect I'll be
effect thank you you're welcome the
other thing even though it wasn't
in part two or what we're considering
hb2 around around the um permitting uh
the governor's sense of trying to
streamline permitting and making it
easier to do that um it does affect you
this is particular I think how it
affects you with the threatened and
endangered species
compensatory mitigation fund um I guess
assuming if someone's putting in a
permit which is going to have an
environmental effect um this all kicks
in how does what she's proposing here
how will it impact you and your ability
to um get this work done so what she's
proposed definitely has a significant
impact on us um to be upfront we are
100% behind the governor's initiative
and and desire for efficiency government
efficiency and One-Stop shopping for the
applicants things like that whatever we
can do to improve that however in our
agency environmental review is not
limited to aot permits or permits that
go just through Dees we have other
environmental reviews that we conduct
for other entities including reviews for
NEPA and federal organizations for
nonprofits that are trying to get
federal grants so if all four of those
positions are removed from our agency we
will have no capacity or very limited I
won't say no limited capacity to do that
work um we are working with the other
agencies involved and discussing an
alternative approach um what would be
the ideal is you know if if this is to
move forward that we at least retain at
the minimum one perhaps two of those
positions to maintain our own
consistency and our own um uh
requirements for uh environmental review
there is of course some concern about
the redundancy across two agencies
there's concern about the uh the
increase in in uh funding to create this
group in Dees there are other uh excuse
me other concerns that have been raised
but nonetheless what we're going to do
is you know wherever it lands we're
going to make it work we're going to
make it be effective I do have concerns
about our agency being completely
stripped of the ability to do our jobs
um you know I want to support the
governor but I also have an agency that
I need to make sure we're meeting our
mandates uh I do have concerns that we
we work together with Dees and dancer
and ensure that we're minimizing in any
potential increase in litigations
because of the review process the last
thing we need is for New Hampshire to
all of a sudden be in the spotlight for
more litigation so there are there's a
lot of work that needs to go into this
um I'm not saying it's impossible we I'm
just saying we need to be smart about
how we approach it and uh yes I it does
impact us significantly so if I
understand correctly just make sure that
I do if this went through the way it is
written you would lose the positions you
have they would all go into this other
yes stream and that would mean that
reviews that you are supposed to do that
you're perhaps required to do would not
get done or do you think they would get
done over here they just wouldn't get
done I don't they would they would not
get would not get done as far as I know
I mean we would obviously we're not
going to try to get to that point we're
going to work through some way that this
stuff is addressed but yes thank
you R of papovich thank you Mr chair
um last fall during the revenue uh
committee we were talking about the uh
direct and indirect cost for search and
rescue if you remember the department
was stating that um they don't you know
they don't get enough uh funds and that
is a cost imposed on them we went
through the whole report submitted to
the fiscal committee which seem to show
that the hike Safeguard and other
revenues seem to properly reimburse the
department and then I was told that you
know there are a bunch of indirect costs
stuff like regular pay for the officers
involved that are not reported to fiscal
and I did ask you guys at the time if
there is any way you could start
breaking down that uh internal data so
that we can get a better understanding
of what the true cost of search and
rescue is to fish and game I just wanted
to see if you had any update on anything
that was done any anywhere you are on
that
[Music]
discussion do you have anything for
I do not so yes I I did request that and
as far as I know that report is being
generated for me at this time but I did
not have it available to bring today it
would be appre obviously I would
appreciate an update whenever you guys
have it it's an issue that we need to
continue working on to make sure
everything is properly accounted for
thank you fully understand yes sir and I
would like to add if there is another
format that you would like to work with
me on for presenting the search and rest
your report I'm more than willing to
work through Mickey to design a
different
format thank you I I would be happy to
help in any way obviously if we're
talking about a meaningful involvement I
would suggest waiting until after the
budget is done because my I can say the
same it is uh it is the last time I've
been let's see I I missed three days
last week and that was the first time
this year I wasn't here 5 days a week so
my my time right now is limited but I
will be happy to help I just want to
point out that we're not looking at as
much as a format as where we are looking
at including the full range of costs
that you guys are incurring right now
you are reporting on a partial range of
costs and some costs you just absorb
without reporting them to fiscal and I'm
trying to help you guys better show
fiscal what you're really dealing with
so you we can create the appropriate
funding and you
know resources that you need to perform
that job so you know if we don't show
them what you really are spending on it
they don't see a need for reimbursement
so I would be happy you know I don't
want to volunteer anybody other than
myself but I would be happy to you know
go through a more you know lowlevel
analysis if you feel it would help and
uh you know suggest any you know
improvements one page report is strictly
the accounting unit 2117 and the
activity in that accounting unit I would
foresee it as being like an addendum
more an attachment to that report sure
we can definitely go into the weeds if
you so choose yeah thank you can I just
clarify earlier you were speaking about
the governor reducing the funding for
was it conservation law enforcement 7887
yes okay so I see that she took away the
general funds y but she increased the
fish and game fund yep okay so why did
you need to reduce the number of people
did I misunderstand what was going on
there because she balanced the budget
so she balanced it but because it's
based on lapses you're not going to you
release people or not replace people or
what we don't know yet we're we're in
discussions internally about that okay
so this is this is not necessarily
something that it's cast in stone you've
actually eliminated people and you're
not going to be able to get
environmental no we have not absolutely
eliminated people no we have vacancies
that are open right now we're filling
one of them the question is whether we
continue to fill the rest or not
assuming the lapse otherwise if we C if
we had that certainty of that general
fund we wouldn't even question it we
would automatically fulfill those okay
so it's not cast in stone that
everything you described is going to
necessarily happen right
correct so you know on the fishing game
funds where you have the increase to 6.2
million um this is her expectation of
what you
will reach at that level no it's not an
expectation all it did was the default
of course is the fishing game fund so
when you take out a fund the default
fund thank you everything else remained
equal
yes which you know um that's it's
suitable I mean it makes sense it's okay
however it's not uh the way that we
prefer to operate uh you know clearly in
2000 I think it was 15 we reached that
low Point again but again we have so
much uh infrastructure and other things
that need attention we have it needs and
I would much prefer to be able to use
some of that those funds to elevate this
agency to the current
Sentry we have people who cannot even do
their time sheets because they don't
have access to the internet and our
hatcheries and Regional we're working
through that right now but it's so it's
just a matter of figuring out where we
land and then how we what we can
accomplish over the next buum so back to
the discussion we about earlier please
get me the information about yes sir
restricted funds where we can increase
fees maybe unrestrict funds and so on
and so forth because maybe that's a a
solution to the concerns that you're
raising absolutely
representative thank you thank you again
um you you have a substantial amount of
federal funds and usually we don't need
to look at federal funds you know that's
fine we're we're really happy you get
that um are you are there any concerns
are any Flags coming up around federal
funds in terms of funds that are going
to be withheld or don't disappear um
what are your concerns in that regard uh
yeah I would say we're probably middle
of the road right now we have some
concerns because we did just get
notification that one of our funds is on
hold and we can no longer charge against
it we've already of course with with
Federal you get a reimbursement so we've
already expended funds that we may have
to cover if we can no longer charge to
that Grant um at this point that's the
only one that we are definitive on there
are a couple other grants that have been
in discussions I'm not sure where those
are going to land um certainly if if
federal funds are put to a halt we will
we will be struggling at least for the
half do you know I do not off the top of
my head but all of our federal funds
which would
be Federal is federal PR DJ are um in
annual
apportionments and Noah we bring in 8 to
11 million a year in federal funds let
me see I may actually have it here in
one of my papers I might be able to tell
you that but um one point I will make is
that one encouraging thing that is
happening in DC and may affect us in the
long term is there's been a movement to
consider the ex the excise taxes on
online purchases
that come from out of country so that if
they can get that pass that will help
all of us across the nation um the
federal grants over the last uh fiscal
year I guess was just over was that
right just over a million there or five
million yeah so over over 10 million
over the last fiscal year we did have a
reduction of about well let's see total
that's 20 about 10% reduction that's
just PR and DJ so that does not include
the Noah grants yeah I'm sorry I was
absolutely absolutely repr d a strange
question are we still doing Northwood
law and if we are do you get money for
that I knew we couldn't get out of this
meting without that question so we are
looking at um potentially Rec
Contracting with the original producers
um we'll be bringing that before uh
Governor counsel if it moves forward the
thing is that uh initially they're
they're changing their format they're
looking at doing short sort of YouTube
clips videos and rather than a TV show
so with that in mind um the initial uh
proposal would be that there would be no
revenue and except for them to sell ads
and once they started selling ads um
they then may make donations to the
Heritage
Foundation for us as an agency to ask
for funding for that it's a little
awkward we spoke with the AG's office
it's not really appropriate for us as an
agency to do so however if they want to
donate to the Heritage Foundation by all
means they can and that's how they
managed the payments last time as they
made donations to the Heritage
Foundation we did we do yeah through
through grants through grants again that
I had spoken of very early in the
meeting so more to
come any other questions gotta go
okay so that's
it thank you thank you very much I
appreciate it can do okay thank you and
I guess with that we'll unless anybody
ma'am just a quick question would you
like to revisit your retirement
date would I like I already have and I
assured director simic that keep talking
years I'm hoping I'm hoping to retain
her thank
you certain so that'll close the
division two meeting thank you 325 years
21 with fishing game almost 30 with the
state I was at Dees for first that's
what I thought in this job I asked you
years ago if you were from Kingston
directon
e